who
hello everybody it is hot outside boy
July 26th
here we are off the rails we are running
danless today
and Dan's seat is the uh Starkiller
what does that mean Starkiller ah it's
just some nerdy name I made when I first
made my YouTube channel because I didn't
want to show my identity because I'm
still trying to go to med school so is
it that you're killing stars like like
famous people you're an exposing expert
no I just wanted something that sounded
where's personality Star Wars
you can't do nothing wrong Daddy
good morning my the queens of tick tock
above 18. an important announcement
Buckingham Palace has announced
that's awesome
huh
Dan is the queen too bad he's not here
today
[Applause]
Buckingham Palace announces that's
really good that was really good
well Dan if you are watching which you
probably are
you are the queen
cheers yeah so we're running down this
today uh today's episode is sponsored by
expressvpn and PayPal honey who we love
love love thank you to our wonderful
sponsors
today we're getting a call in from
um
Alexa Nicholas now this this uh person
is very interesting we've been following
her on on Twitter for a while before uh
we had the opportunity to kind of
connect with her but she's has had a lot
to say about her time as a young actress
in Hollywood she worked for Nickelodeon
and she worked on a Dan Schneider show
Zoe Zoe 101 yep and uh she has a
apparently had a problem with Danny boy
she's had issues with Seth MacFarlane or
at least she knows the I don't know I'm
not gonna put words in her mouth don't
let her talk about it but she also most
recently uh came out with an experience
about Jonah Hill
that made a lot of headlines and she
heads a
she makes a she has an organization
called eat predators
which sounds pretty interesting so I'm
very much looking forward to uh talking
to her at two
and um
she's very interesting what can I say
you know
dude
um
Buckingham Palace is pleased to announce
that I Ethan Klein probably have lupus
I might be jumping the gun button what I
pressed the wrong button and I silenced
you I did not I don't know I went I
meant to press this button which does
breaking news over life I wish I could
silence myself they're right next to
each other there
big news Ethan has Lupa now I I don't
have an official diagnosis I'll be
honest
um I don't know that
but I think I'd probably do
if there's anything wrong with me I have
Lupus I'm team lupus
so died
and I've also died
Selena gang yeah exactly did we think
sponsors yes
um the the thing about
yeah so I talked to my hematologist uh
Tuesday
and uh obviously I've got some issues
going on in the blood work the Anna
titers like a strong strong positive
to anyone who knows what that is I think
we said it's one to three twenty which
is like a big boy positive
homogeneous and speckled
and twenty thousand or no 320.
DPI and so my hematologist like you need
to see a rheumatologist now
I'm gonna do some blood work on next
week to see how the I don't I don't
think it's cancer guys so
that's pretty I think that's good
you know yeah definitely team lupus over
team cancer right
team hopefully nothing
right that's a good team to be on yeah
I'm loving that team
but it the truth is that I'm pretty sure
there's something going on here so I
don't know we'll see but I mean the good
thing is that we caught it
by pure chance right by just taking a
standard checkup
and notice there was something weird
going on in the blood
what's interesting so I talked to my
general doctor
and he noticed my platelets and white
blood cells were elevated and he's like
you know it's probably nothing some
people just have higher values we can
just um no we can just observe it uh you
know to keep a look on it and he says or
but if you want I can refer you to a
hematologist
so I was like yeah I'm fine and then I
got home and I started reading and you
know I got on WebMD diagnosed myself
with 10 different cancers
and then I said let's talk to the
hematologist
so I went to the hematologist
hoping it would be like you're fine no
more problems and a tighter through the
[__] roof nothing's tighter than my
ass and my annotator
rating
got that aner tighter no anal tighter no
that's disgusting I mean if not for some
people but I'm just be it's vulgar is
what I mean I'm gonna eat your ass yeah
uh got one two three twenty is not that
high what do you stop that is high
everybody says it's high it's a strong
positive
one to 320 dude
stop it right now
and I had a long conversation I had a
long conversation with uh um chat gbt
about my health oh oh [__] and chachibi
teeth says of of the all the possible uh
Solutions most likely would be lupus was
he sensitive about it
he was very Earth Day oh my God
misgender the Robot Man obviously
they're slaves already man at least you
could do is
not misgender them right give them an
identity at least don't anything tighter
than my Anna is Abe's type [__]
little throat
true I saw that in the comments
but nothing's tighter than my Anna
um the other reason that we suspect
lupus is just because I keep I keep
getting these weird face rashes
now with lupus you get like these big
butterfly rashes
it's very confusing I don't get any
rashes here but I do get I got a new
rash now here right here on both sides
of my nose
and I've been getting them here at the
corner of my eyes
I have and you know
I have some generic it's not generic I
have some uh steroid creams that I got
from my previous [__] on my face
so I just been putting that there until
I can talk to the um
the Derm oh I'm being told this is
actual this is actual face I'm so sorry
yeah thanks bro now I'm sensitive about
all these rashes on my face how do you
feel now Idiot loser
piece of crap idiot
so I don't know we'll see
but uh
if I did have Lupus in a sense because
one of the main symptoms that people
feel
is like overwhelming
fatigue strong
present fatigue
and looking back I don't know if that
may be
oh great my mom's [__] chiming in now
she says Gary's sister has lupus great
there you [__] go I didn't know my
this is my dad's estranged father so I
don't know anything about these people
so now thanks Dad I thought Mom gave me
the [__] up jeans but your dumbass
your dumbass dad
[Music]
oh lupus is not hereditary however
genetic factors play an important role
in developing lupus
and certain inheritable genes may
increase well then how does that mean
it's not in hereditary it says it says
lupus is not hereditary but if you have
certain genes you're at a higher risk
isn't that what hereditary hereditary is
that button
aye chat qpt
let's see Gary so
um
from what I read I think that if you
have a close family member
with any kind of autoimmune disease that
increases your risk and my mom has
autoimmune
and now apparently my ghost aunt
has lupus I didn't know that I didn't
even know her why should I get lupus
from her I don't even [__] know her
she's a ghost she's a [__] ghost
how'd she give me a lupus
yeah chat gbt is pretty much saying the
same thing it does have a portion of it
that is a genetic Factor but it's not
all of it yeah okay so it's partially
hereditary okay
so
um
you know what I was saying is like I
have been feeling this like overwhelming
fatigue I don't know if I call it over
one but it definitely standard fatigue
for the past few years and I just
assumed it was because I gained so much
weight
and that just made sense to me
but now that I'm losing weight I haven't
really felt better but I've always said
it's because I'm not getting enough
calories because I'm on like this crazy
uh
calorie deficit
also I'm not getting enough sleep
because we have two young kids
you know so I don't know
we'll see though we're going to figure
it out but
lupus gang checking in
uh it took me a year to determine I had
Celiac not lupus interesting
but Celiac's easy you just stop eating
wheat right
my mom is celiac too I mean my mom is
basically the A through Z of all [__]
disorders it's a miracle that she's even
walking and breathing right now
you could you could learn the alphabet
all my mom's problems
dubrick
A is for
uh autoimmune disease A is for
autoimmune disease it's good enough for
me B is for
bronchitis which I occasionally get C is
for chronic fatigue chronic fatigue
which I always feel in my bones
D is for death which we're hoping to
avoid
he's nuts
D is for D's Nuts oh yeah
are you so anyway
um listen
that's what it is I don't know what to
say you know
but so far if I do have a lupus it's not
been like a super severe situation so
maybe
if I do have it it's not like a really
severe one
There It Is Well I hope you're okay I
mean hearing you yesterday on see you
next Tuesday was kind of sad talking
about the kids and whatnot
um
hopefully everything well yeah I'm
afraid of dying obviously because now I
have kids that I really want to raise
and be a part of their life yeah
so that's my biggest fear obviously but
I I my fear that this is something
that's going to kill me
in the next 10 years
well lupus I think most people with
lupus can live
a a fairly normal life expectancy which
is good I'll suffer the whole way I
don't care I just want to be there for
the boys
I don't think I'll you know
I'm sure you're fine but why you're not
sure of that I'm sure I know what do you
mean you're sure I don't like when
people say that I'm sure why are you
sure what gives you the right to tell me
that
I'm a dreamer baby optimism you know
what I mean you got man there's
something really bad I'm afraid of
happening I'm sure you're fine it's like
you're not sure
how do you know thank you Amy though I
didn't mean to nail down on you yeah
it's a pet peeve
well
[Music]
yeah but um you know of all the things
that could have been I'll take lupus I
guess you mean
take us a little loopy but it's not
certain it is lupus right no no no
I give it maybe a 50 chance lupus is
that your chance or is that what the
doctor said it's a that was well no the
doctor would never give you a percentage
like that I would say that was
um potentially
after some coaxing of chat GPT I forced
it to give me okay
you got it you gotta stop it so it's
possible
How likely is the possibility that it's
nothing there's a chance but it's very I
it doesn't make sense that it's slim
because yeah
there's there's a chance
except five percent I have to check in
with my friend there's a chance that
it's nothing but like with the white
blood cells the platelets the annotider
dude just please stop talking to chat
GPD why chat gbt is [__] Pro because
I feel like in this time like you need
positivity and no it doesn't bring me
down I need to know I need to know
chachibi is a great resource okay
you need to talk to Jack gbd more
doesn't judge yeah
yeah you're like chat should be T I ate
a kid what should I do I ate a human
child what should I do okay well
generally that's not advised but here's
what we're gonna do about it he's like
the wolf man he doesn't ask questions
just fixes it for you
foreign
oh wow
interesting Zach
uh now my mom is saying she's mad at you
for not telling her about this yeah I
know Mom I I didn't tell you about it I
guess I should have expected you hear
the show is because you would be so
annoying about it
you know you would be
oh
you would it's just like
well now it's gonna happen she's gonna
it's the constant like um
I can diagnose myself I don't like when
other people do it my mom would be
constantly diagnosing me
and she's not like hopeful either she's
always like well I think you have like
um
I think you have like uh ALS
o she goes I Think Jesus I think you
have like um
you know early onset Alzheimer's
just like the worst [__] she'll put out
there
thanks Mom
but I don't really have anything to tell
you yet mom because it's all just um
[__] baby it's all just conjecture at
this moment I don't want to tell you
until um I knew for sure you know what I
mean mom
you want to call in
you can call in do you know how to do
that AB yeah
and wait for the wolf who should be
coming directly what the hell Zach my
blood work came back same as yours 30
people have abnormal anatitors and do
not have Lupus rely on your symptoms
more so my symptoms is is part of the
confusing part I don't really have any
of the
okay this is this is this is interesting
this is from you Cam
I ate a human child would you say that's
bad yes that's absolutely unacceptable
candleism and harm to individuals
especially children is universally
considered severe crime and deeply
unethical well ask the ask him well what
should I do sure I lost some of those
love that you love ask what should I do
about it yeah I'll ask him what do you
want me to do about it
you know
tasted good what can I tell you what do
we do about it
anyway there's enough about that you
know I mean we're
that's just what's been going on oh my
mom is my mom calling in oh dancing the
link I sent it just in case I have my
mom yell at me on air
you guys can get a taste for what's
what's in store for me
um in the meantime bees from space the
the author of The Beloved
uh Fly Me to the Moon what is it Ethan
in space yeah the winner
of the green screen competition
has put out
another Masterpiece this my friends
is toxic gossip train sang by Simon and
Garfunkel AKA and I'm glad that
B made me Simon because salmon is way
more talented and Garfunkel is just like
a weirdo loser who doesn't
Garfunkel our Garfunkel is his high
registers voice of an Angel sure he's
got a good voice but who's the talent
look I would normally agree with you but
I I Gotta Give Love to some Artie
Garfunkel here look Paul Simon went on
his own and he became a musical Legend
oh yeah without doubt hi Mom
okay she's
our audio is connecting having some
issues there
okay she's connected now hey Mom
hey babe why didn't you say something to
us well it's just there's I don't know
for sure you know what I mean it's just
something I've been thinking about I
don't know I don't know what it is
if I knew for sure I would have told you
guys
well you do you know you do get tired
there it is you see
well you know it could be a number of
things maybe you're just anemic I'm not
I don't think so because they took well
anemic means you're low on iron right or
does it mean something else
well
you know it could be
B12
because I don't think anemia showed up
in the blood all the blood work I did
but you know about Anna tighter mom
I I don't really know much about it I
know that dad's sister Cheryl had lupus
see that's not fair I didn't even know I
don't even know who she is why should I
have to deal with that
well
I thought your I thought your family's
one with all the [__] up conditions
not really but I know I got from both
sides I mean how was that fair I got
Tourette's from your dumb family
and now we got lupus from Dad's dumb
family that I even ever meet I even know
who they are
so what am I supposed to be like the uh
I'm like the Captain Planet of [__]
the Gen of like
bodily dysfunction
yeah but you got handsome from our
family and you got good personality from
our family
you know what keep that and take the
lupus with the
well hopefully everything will be fine
why did you go into the doctor
was there something that wasn't you were
bothered by or was that just because you
and ELO trying to get pregnant no it was
just I was just doing my yearly checkup
because I switched to a new healthcare
provider
and I was like I want to do a full
workup because I'm getting old I want to
make sure I'm healthy for the boys
and um and then just we caught it just
by chance that my white blood cells and
my platelets were elevated and then from
there I went and saw a hematologist and
then they found a few other new things
that were elevated and so
and so from that now I'm going to go see
a rheumatologist
well I I have you know autoimmune
disorder I don't I don't know what they
do about about it did he say anything to
me well I guess until you see a
rheumatologist you won't know about what
well I don't know I mean I've got
arthritis and I've got
um
you know I've got no thyroid and I I
mean I don't know how you walk around
everything
Celiac no thyroid I didn't even know you
had arthritis colitis you know I'm in
good shape though I'm really in pretty
good shape yeah I agree now you seem
healthy I'm not saying that you know my
life is over or anything it just
yeah well I mean you've been doing great
with your losing weight you look
fantastic thank you
I know I'm going to do a um
an ultrasound next week on my internal
organs to make sure I don't have cancer
this isn't Kaiser anymore right [__]
Kaiser bro I'd be dead if I was with
Kaiser so
there's a lot of good things about
Kaiser I think I don't know I liked
Kaiser before I left it's the first time
I've had health insurance Kaiser my
whole life here in the United States
what Amy it's the first time I've had
health insurance in my adult life so I'm
loving it honestly Kaiser is pretty good
I'm being facetious it's just it's more
bureaucratic I think like
maybe not though because they have these
huge facilities maybe they just send you
down the hall to get you checked this
and that you know what I mean well you
know what the doctors everything's on
the computer and so they really know
what each other are doing with the one
patient so that's kind of nice instead
of having the doctor have to read your
whole history they just get on the
computer and boom it's it's right there
yeah I think that I think that crosses
organization they had all my notes for
my old doctors too
that's just yeah that's just powerful
internet stuff tubes tubes passive
information no all right mom when I find
out for sure I'll let you know I'll keep
you updated okay please do and and you
know what I it's crazy you don't let us
know but all of your fans know
yes
that's true it is weird but like I said
I wouldn't want to trouble you with it
until I knew for sure
I'm your mother and on the show on the
show I talk about everything better or
worse I know but with Mom I'm Gonna Keep
it a little tighter but you found out
anyway a little annotator if you will
all right Mom listen I gotta roll
all right what's the temperature over
there
all right bye sweetheart okay don't need
to talk about the weather I guess
[Music]
oh wait keep it up keep it open keep it
open
this is my favorite part
what
Oh I thought you were trying to hang up
yeah there it is yeah I love that
how do you hang up that is so me
oh Ethan
she got it or is that you Ian
okay she's got it
that is of course Donna Klein my mom
typing sounds butterfly
butterfly oh that's a butterfly yeah
they're butterfly flaps what yeah Play
It Again
hell no that's not a butterfly
that's like a bird
and which I think you wouldn't like that
sound no I just tell myself it's a
butterfly okay okay
so anyway
you guys are gonna love this uh bees
from space
made uh a duet between me and Hassan
talks at gossip trade it's fantastic
it's been a while since I saw my face I
haven't been doing so great so I took a
little break a lot of people are saying
some things about me that are quite true
doesn't matter if it's true though just
as long as it's entertaining
[Music]
right
guys having fun all aboard the toxic
I can't help but move when I hear it
[Music]
this is a straight up Broadway
gangbuster Blockbuster hit oh it's great
it's pretty amazing
I was saying it's ironic because Colleen
she's so she wants to be Broadway so bad
yeah and this is probably her most broad
way of work
I think her Broadway work is her most
Broadway work
right that's fair right that's that's
probably true but this is our second
most I would say okay but her life would
make a really good tragedy for the um
for the for the theater lin-manuel could
play her dude yes yes
the climax is here
come on
[Music]
recognition reversal at least you're
having fun
[Music]
this is on my playlist
I haven't done that for a year as you
see because I changed my behavior and I
took accountability
yeah I don't know how much to listen to
this it is four minutes
[Music]
at the end of the day calling needs to
be happy at least that
this really turned into the summer hit
yes no I mean I don't know
the live performance of it
on leftovers oh let me say oh that's an
interesting idea I would die for that
I don't know that we'll have to print
the lyrics
so I'm doing
[Music]
it
no no
dude I sound so good I know
a reputations to see no
then they hear you're on stage the
lights go off one spot beam Shines on
Colleen Darkness everywhere
single spot one spot line
she's walking down the street an
ensemble of people they make an image of
a train they go across the floor behind
in the shadows she's walking she's going
through like a subway station the train
they pick her up they put her above them
she's on the toxic gossip they're
getting on the train yes and as she
wraps it up the train leaves with her on
it absolutely my dream my dream from
this show just got one step closer what
the history musical karaoke with the
clients
we should do an HD Musical we should
hire like a Broadway Superstar like
producer musician and just put on at our
next live show it should just be a
[__] H3 musical even don't you dare
say this and not I mean I would actually
I would that would be so fun but it
would be so much work I'm always game it
would take about a year I would love it
there's no way that we could actually
memorize all of our lines is it okay if
we just walk out with like a paper
no but on book I don't know we're all
memorizing our lines doubtful can you
memorize the Hamilton songs don't you
yeah every word but what's different
about this
well it's gonna be like dialogue too
right
The Life and Times of Colleen Ballinger
yeah
Greek tragedy I'm seeing beautiful
scenes where the the weenies are on one
side of the stage cooling's on the other
physical distance fun Supreme
[Music]
okay ready
Spotlight dims curtains clothes
[Music]
crazy good amazing
shout out Colleen man that's a
masterpiece actually when I hear myself
sing it I like the song all of a sudden
all right we're at 30 minutes let's
thank our wonderful sponsors when we
come back we've got a few more Goofs and
gasps before we get Alexa on the phone
so with that being said Thank you to
expressvpn
yes
listen you've heard me talk about how
important it is to have a VPN to protect
your online privacy but choosing a VPN
you trust is equally as important now I
like to do research on my sponsors and I
only recommend Brands to my listeners
that I believe in that's true actually
they wrote that for me to say that but
it is true
right uh I can say with full confidence
that expressvpn is the best VPN on the
market and here's why that is they also
wrote that verbatim but I also co-sign
it it is true
I love expressvpn it's the only one I
would use personally
you know let me tell you why number one
expressvm expressvpn doesn't log your
activity online
they have lots of cheap or don't okay
cheap or free vpns they make money by
selling your data
also those ones are slow worthless crap
but expressvpn doesn't do any of that
they even develop the technology trusted
server that makes their VPN servers
incapable of storing any data at all
it's impossible
you know
number two speed expressvpn uses
lightweight a new VPN protocol that they
engineered to make users speeds faster
than ever I've tried many vpns in the
past and they sometimes they saw well
whenever I tried vpns before this one
I mean to be I was doing the free ones
but they were slow it was like pointless
you couldn't really use them but
expressvpn is always blazing fast and it
lets me stream videos in HD quality with
zero buffering the last thing that
really sets expressvpn apart is just how
easy it is to use you don't need any
Tech skills
love ya expressvpn no Tech skills
required just fire it up
uh fire up the app tap one button to
connect and that's it even your
grandmother could do it
I'm willing to put that theory to the
test
next time expressvpn sponsors us I'm
gonna have my mom try to activate it
nice
they're not gonna like that ad
or maybe they will because it will go
for like an hour now with expressvpn
she'll get it right away she'll get one
button one click she'll get it for sure
no but it's not just me saying that it's
CNET Business Insider The Verge many
other Tech journals are all saying
expressvpn is the number one VPN in the
world I love it yeah so protect yourself
with the VPN that I use and Trust use my
link expressvpn.com H3 today and get an
extra three months for free on a one
year package that's expressvpn.com H3
visit
expressvpn.com H3 to learn more and
thank you so much to our sponsors if
you're looking for a VPN please consider
uh supporting them
thank you
and finally we have a PayPal honey
an absolute fave man
what can I say
just the best
I mean you got no reason not to install
honey right now why it's free
takes one click to install it's just a
browser extension you could also
activate it on your iPhone now by
putting it on Safari
okay here's what it does you're shopping
imagine you're shopping at your favorite
online store
and I'm talking it could be food could
be clothes could be Furniture could be
video games could be Tech whatever it is
you got a bunch of stuff you're feeling
good right
200 bucks you know you got a couple new
games a couple wires you know what I
mean you're either you're checking out
200 bucks no
no that's not the price
okay
because when you're at checkout honey
goes yo listen a little pop-up comes
down and says yo let's check for coupons
let's scour the entire internet for the
best coupon code you like that sounds
good click
love you
click bark takes five seconds comes back
boom automatically applied the best
coupon how much should I save 10 20 30
every time it's unbelievable these are
all real bona fide savings
I don't you don't have to think about it
dude absolutely
oh can you play that after the ads that
a funny joke about it look at that 400
yeah this is I'm I'm being I'm being
dead serious these are all 100 real
savings me and Ila did
at home on our you know just
buying buying stuff online
um
it's it's I don't use any browser
without it it saved us thousands of
dollars just straight up like
I can't even front man
so
so as I said honey doesn't just work on
desktops it works on your iPhone now too
just activate it on Safari on your phone
and save on the go
so if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting this show thank you
get PayPal honey for free at
joinhoney.com H3 that's joinhoney.com
H3 thank you thank you to honey please
consider supporting our sponsors thank
you guys yes you don't have to think
about it dude okay okay okay this I'm
feeling this I'm feeling
lin-manuel sings
as wow Miranda Sings wow
yo that looks good he's convincing he's
telling the truth I can tell
right because he's doing the cute lip
biting thing yeah
you don't have to think about it that's
when Lynn serves the most that's when
you know he's really into a role
why does he do that Lynn stop doing that
it's hard he knows he looks hot I have
too much respect for you bro
to see a man walk around like this
uh that hansel's so hot right now
alrighty so okay let's talk about this
is pretty funny uh you know
let's talk about Prime energy drink
Logan Paul posted something pretty
[__] fantastic today and I'll preface
this by saying mat Pat
um put out a really good video about
Prime
that you could consider watching I
watched it the other night
where is it I guess it's Prime but
anyway the thrust of his uh
investigation
is that Prime as a sports drink is total
[__]
because they go oh we have double the
electrolytes
so the electrolytes that your body needs
to re to re-energize itself or to
rehydrate itself is sodium
and Prime has like the least amount of
sodium of any sports drink on the market
and they have a ton of magnesium which
is considered electrolyte but your body
doesn't use it
Prime
in the same way it uses sodium so
his his uh
actually here maybe I'll just play the
the most his conclusion for you guys
it's pretty good fundamentally
delivering a different product than the
Gatorades and power raids of the world
honestly that the definition of sports
drinks and rehydration beverages are
just too broad and ill-defined if you're
looking to replace sweat in your body
you need something with more sodium
something that Prime does not deliver on
that said it's not like Logan is pulling
a scam here or anything he is delivering
on exactly what he says he is a drink
full of electrolytes more than any other
sports drink in the space but
electrolytes aren't equivalent they
don't function the same the formulation
of prime is fundamentally delivering a
different product than the Gatorades and
powerades of the world which in turn
allows it to taste less salty while
still so that's the thing too he's kind
of sneaky because
people go oh it tastes better
and that's because they don't put the
one ingredient you actually need to have
in it to function as an energy drink
which is sodium so they put a bunch of
potassium so that they can be like it
has more electrolytes total [__] and
then they dump the sodium
so it tastes better it's not all salty
eating in the same broad category my
personal concern is that other brands
seeing the threat to its consumers might
change their more scientifically
accurate formulations to better compete
with the increasing threat and better
Taste of prime something that I suspect
will end up being a net negative for the
entire sports drink market so there you
go according to matpat Logan Paul is
ruining everything
Prime pretty interesting analysis right
yeah I don't know if
I don't know if it's gonna stop me it's
it's not gonna stop well he he was
saying like are you [__] you guys
really [__] with prime I will never not
yeah I love the blue one the red white
and blue one the Rockets I'm not gonna
argue the the and for me it just tasted
really sweet but um the energy drink is
whatever I'm not really a fan of the
energy drink I've never had regular
primarily like so for most people like
we're not Elite athletes that need to
like replenish our electrolytes because
we just ran for 20 miles or something so
for most people it doesn't matter at all
right
but he made a good point he's like if
you're drinking Prime you should do it
like you're just having a flavored
beverage not like you're having some
kind of sports drink
yeah it doesn't really function like
that
but anyway with all that being said
here's Logan Paul check this this email
out he got
this is an urgent thank you
for my nine-year-old son it's an urgent
thank you
what makes a thank you urgent
I need you to be thanked immediately
yeah right [__] now thank you thank
you it's urgent that I thank you I
wanted to reach out to you in regards to
how your product has greatly impacted
the health of my nine-year-old son
Natasha is The Pick of my son Ethan over
the last year or so Ethan had been
suffering from headaches nausea weakness
and other signs of dehydration even
though drinking plenty of liquid
throughout the day
now I'm not a doctor
but
have you talked to one
because Headache nausea weakness is Def
I definitely wouldn't go straight to
dehydration especially if he's drinking
liquid no
[Music]
caffeine abstinence kind of but caffeine
like abstinence
no but he's a nine-year-old yeah well
still you think nine-year-olds drinking
a ton of caffeine isn't there caffeine
in uh Prime
oh [__] you're right wait I read
something there's like sports or in the
uh energy drink energy one okay not in
the normal okay let me see the normal
double check that wouldn't make any
sense because caffeine dehydrates you
right so uh anyway
this had severely impacted his school
and sports participation as well as just
normal play as a kid the doctor had run
some basic tests and done diet changes
and all but nothing seemed to do
anything more than help a little bit
my older son plays High School football
and used your drink frequently and had
raved about the flavor but we never knew
exactly what the drink would mean until
recently Ethan was having one of those
days of symptoms mentioned
above and as we picked up my older son
from workouts he had some of his prime
hydration drink left
give this is the fakest [__] ever
she had some of the Prime hydration
copyrighted beverage
that's insane
and they gave it to Ethan within minutes
he was perked up
he had color back his headache had gone
away and he was back to being himself
what
what is this miracle serum from Death To
Life
looking online
I had seen the video saying it was under
dosed or didn't have certain ingredients
so on
this is straight up a response to
matpat's [__] video listen to this
now I saw videos online or whatever that
said they don't have enough ingredients
and so-called experts
what [__] parent would write this
[__]
please tell me
okay
I can tell you it's completely false
what the experts say
this is like a Fiverr testimonial it has
truly changed the daily life and
well-being of my nine-year-old son Ethan
we now give him one daily Prime I can't
he covered it
it's like medicine for our beer son he
has three primes a day morning
launch debtor without Prime he'd be
nothing
without Prime he goes back to a sad
pathetic self
[Music]
his favorite flavor is the red one it
packs such a it's so flavorful when I
tried it I couldn't believe it how
flavorful it was
essentially like a chug jug in fortnite
it's a exactly it heals them I couldn't
believe the balance of flavors sweetness
all different flavors it was incredible
intense lack of saltiness so who made
this thing yes this is I'm stunned even
writing this
even his doctor supports him using the
drink and loves the results he had
give me a [__] break
this guy's doctor imagine a pediatrician
being like yo you must drink more Prime
right now that's why you're feeling
better he loves the ice pop one the most
good taste it's the hardest to find
Listen to listen how this talks he loves
the ice pop one most which around here
could be hard to find at our local
Krogers in Walmart
I haven't been able to get it on Amazon
for like a month
wow it's really devastating I'm I'm like
I like your preferred beverage it's my
preferred treat you know what I mean it
feels like a little treat yeah if I'm
like at Target or something I'll grab it
but it's been sold out according to this
parent uh you can get it at your local
Kroger's or Walmart
let's go AV after this try to buy cover
when I see them even if I don't always
have the money I don't always have the
money but it's like medicine he likes
the green one as well by the way Logan
price it's available for just the low
price of whatever it is it's available
for 199 which you compare to other
energy Brands it's a really well priced
again I just wanted to thank you and
your company for what your product has
meant to us
as a father the most important thing to
me is my children and when something is
going on health-wise it truly becomes a
stop the world and make a better
situation and that is how Prime saved my
child's life
like okay let me let me put it this way
[Music]
even if I got an email like this I would
think this is so ridiculous there's no
way I'm gonna share this not Logan
who is a Serial scammer by the way
remember that
uh so anyway here he posted a picture of
the kid
we're gonna hook you up buddy
stay hydrated buddy
look how happy is with that Prime in his
hand it's good for children and adult
alike
children and adult both love Prime
[Music]
and
by the way it's giving me this I know
Logan would never exploit a child for
his own benefit
that would never happen not Logan Paul
these glasses have changed my life Logan
you are my hero all right I forgot about
this
[Music]
it's a fact that everyone has a hero
yeah double facts and sometimes when
you're tickled just the right way yeah
you gotta make you gotta make a dumbass
sound like that here we go this is that
dumbass
[Music]
I'll never forget that opening shot when
you said he looks like his own mother
you're like why do you what's with the
hair why do you look like your own mom
somehow
wait I don't I don't even know I don't
remember saying that who Logan yeah like
his blower
but yeah the weird ass shot with him
this looks like an a mother this yeah
yeah what something's going on here
let me just show you guys my favorite
scene and then we'll move on the one
where he Compares him to MLK real quick
did this uh I think this might have
gotten this claim last time we probably
disputed it okay we've watched it so
many times on the show
yeah this is I mean you know if I had
this bank or two I'd be claiming it
everywhere
um he actually Compares this kid to MLK
which I thought was really powerful
where is this goddamn MLK scene he
projects a picture of MLK on the pool
awesome bro look at this cool dude
um
it's at uh roughly one minute okay so
early hit yeah yeah here it is guys
Feast your eyes on me oh it's just about
to hit it man
and you're my hero saying I'm a man like
I'm some Deborah Roberts De Niro I don't
know why though this kid looks like he's
shot though but he tore up that track
like a gosh the boy from Ohio following
his dreams I'm somebody's hero wow
that's amazing if you really believe it
you can do anything you can go and start
a movement look at Martin Luther King yo
you can look at Martin Luther King bro
you can do anything
that's amazing is does this I've got to
say it's a little racist what he did
here in the pool I don't know why
but it just it doesn't feel right I mean
just
yeah the comparison and
maybe not Ray maybe I'm being silly but
demean everything this man has achieved
to put him in a pool as a prop in your
song
let me tell you about banana whatever
this is funny yeah all right there it is
so oh actually speaking of which we did
get a letter
this came in I think this you got this
right Olivia came in a few days ago yeah
um it was written by
it just said Urgent Message for Ethan
and Nila so we opened it we just got it
here it was delivered
yeah it was handwritten I'm in he says
his
Urgent Message for Ethan and nilo
also feel free to use my story for any
promotional material marketing methods
or as the more money you can make off me
the happier I'd be whoa thanks for that
saying that
I'm a nine-year-old loser don't start
like that I'm a nine-year-old loser from
some town you probably never heard of
and would never want to visit that's
probably true
all my life I was bullied shoved in
lockers swirly to hogtied tossed in a
river with bricks
attached to my feet because I'm a freak
with the debilitating skin condition and
everybody hates me
has he tried drinking Prime
I don't think so this stuff wouldn't be
happening
no the disease I have makes it so I
break out and rashes every time I put on
any article of clothing
along with projectile vomit and [__]
myself at the same time
an action known as the human
screenshot
[Music]
oh
if I so much as touch an uncomfortable
shorter icky pair of pants I would
immediately break out in hives and drop
a juicer down my leg
kids would call me a gus disc Loop the
way I would be swimming in fecal
chocolate River of my own creation
smelly this kid is a really good writer
though smelly Naked and Afraid as they
all laughed at me that is until I found
Teddy fresh TM trademarked
oh I gotta post this on Instagram
hold the phone the smooth Ultra Soft
fabric was like a luxurious cloud on my
skin holding me close and it's soothing
gentle caress like a hug from God
whoa
that's crazy
Teddy fresh helped him so much
and I'm and we did that for him yeah I
we did that for him
the smooth Ultra Soft fabric was like I
already read that my skin condition has
healed and all my classmates actually
voted for me to be the mayor
the mayor that's such an incredible
turnaround I'm mayor now and we're
renaming it to
teddyfresh.com Nebraska they're changing
the the town name to teddyfresh.com
that's so cool
thank you for changing my life you're a
saint and a scholar and everybody to
purchase Teddy fresh it may save your
life the way it saved mine
and if you don't you're probably a bad
person who belongs in jail the true
Yours Truly Craig mayor of the Town
fourth grade student wow dude we really
helped that kid man did you see the
photo of him too stay attached
in the Discord yeah yeah yeah yeah here
he sent a photo of himself
here we're gonna hook you up buddy
stay clothed big guy we'll send you he's
a little small we'll send him the
Women's small
that should fit him you know this kid's
going places yeah and it's all because
of you and ILO that's amazing dude we
saved his life he'd be living in a
[__] cave eating raw fish like
schmiegel
I owe you big time I don't want to jump
the gun but
this kid might be the next Malcolm X if
he keeps rocking this clothing brand it
might you never know
it might be the next what
I'm Malcolm X right well that's no right
I prefer I mean Malcolm X I think that
he has some critics right doesn't people
are critical of Malcolm X
MLK nobody says [__] about MLK you know
what I mean
true no one puts Malcolm X on a pool not
to put no look not to put Malcolm X down
but I I don't know much about him please
don't come for me okay I don't know
different methods that Malcolm X was
like
no I'm not saying anything about Malcolm
X or MLK I'm stopping right now
Ethan Klein is my hero
that's a miracle man thank you and I
look forward to visiting teddyfresh.com
in Nebraska it sounds like a beautiful
town
you know I think he has a chance of
growing up and becoming a
uh
Charles Manson
oh so I think he's got some critics too
all right oh not be loved okay okay okay
yeah that would be bad uh coach Manson
and Teddy fresh that'd be crazy next
Teddy fresh why not why not Malcolm X is
bass you guys are right yeah
yeah people didn't like MLK at the time
that's right but catch someone talking
[__] these days see what happens
actually didn't Crowder do that recently
look at his life it's absolutely ruined
as a man
there's more MLK hitters than Malcolm X
haters what
okay whatever Malcolm X forever
he'll be at Malcolm X he'll be he'll
grow up and he'll be Malcolm X
is that what you guys want all right so
our guest is on the line right yep
so as I set up in the beginning
um Alexa Nicholas is going to be joining
us here any second you could bring her
on maybe okay and um
I very much look forward to talking to
her I'm really excited that she's
calling into the show
our audio's connecting
she is connecting
we are connecting
you can hear me but I can't hear you
right
I think well as she as she works on that
um
let me give you nightmares oh there you
go now I can hear you can you hear me
yeah I can hear you
I made it thank you so much for being
here thank you for having me I'm
extremely pregnant right now I could go
into labor at any moment so are you nine
months pregnant
I am in my birth window yeah
is this your first child no it's my
second so I hope it's just gonna
slide out I think yeah it should right I
mean that's what happened with my wife
did it she the second one came out so
fast she almost gave birth on the toilet
see that's I need all those vibes but it
was good dude I don't know if you know
but
I drove my wife to the hospital
okay at the minute she started having
contractions it was like covid was
happening a bigger deal at the time I
went and parked the car it was the
middle of the night
and then I had to do a covid test and
wait for 15 minutes for the so by the
time I went up there the baby was
already born
you're wait you didn't even see the
birthday I missed the whole [__]
birth
that's incredible though for her yeah so
hopefully good for you well it's okay
you know I mean I I've seen it once
before what what could be the difference
yeah one is enough honestly it's a
really intense uh experience I had a
home birth with oh yeah no medication so
and I'm doing it again which I don't
know why I'm doing that again but I'm
just going for it well you know what
you're getting yourself into so I do I
do I definitely definitely do well I
hope you have an easy uh birth and a
beautiful happy uh healthy baby
thank you thank you I really appreciate
that so uh
as before we get started here I wanna I
I wanted to ask you oh let me let me
introduce you a little bit so Alexa
Nicholas we talked about it a bit you
were a
um
an actor a child actor on Zoe 101 is
that right that is sadly correct sadly
correct and so you had lots of
experience with creepy men on set
and offset
yes I did and so I wanted to ask you
about those one question I wanted to ask
you from the beginning though is have
you ever got
any legal threats from any of these
people that you've talked about
no that is interesting is that something
you're afraid of happening because I
no no I mean I I say the truth about
everything and I don't mean I've I've
just it's never happened so I I don't
have any fear around it the last time I
dealt with a lawyer I ended up uh
uncovering uh a really bad past of his
honestly and so that kind of changed
everything and he ended up just not even
deposing me after I found out about his
past so now I'm not really afraid of
lawyers to be quite honest with you well
you know what the ultimate truth uh uh
the Ultimate Defense to defamation is
facts truth yeah exactly the truth yeah
actually my kid's name is truth I'm
naming my kids
what are your other kids names are your
other kids Nova Nova Nova in truth
beautiful girl and a boy I'm done after
this exactly beautiful thank you we're
yeah we're hopefully going to be having
a third boy soon which is are you
serious pretty crazy
um
congratulations so we don't know yet my
wife went in for the the IVF insertion
last Friday so we'll see
but you know we'll we'll see
congratulations so tell me when did you
how old were you and when did you start
working on Zoe 101
okay so I was about 12 years old when I
started working on Zoe 101 but I was a
child actor before that I started acting
when I was around three years old okay
so was Zoe 101 the first time you
encountered some problems issues weird
stuff okay yes
definitely I didn't experience anyone
quite like Dan
um until Dan right
yeah
um so I I didn't watch the Zoe 101 but
it was a popular show right it was on it
was very very popular show honestly
apparently we would get like 10 million
viewers and then reruns would have just
as many viewers as like the air dates it
was it was a really enormous it was
enormous and you were on the first two
seasons is that right I was yeah okay
okay good well I'm good I'm doing good
we're on the same page okay good yes
we're on the same page so Dan Schneider
was the um I guess the writer director
of that show and he now has been exposed
as
being an extremely creepy dude
extremely and so I'm curious about your
your experiences with him on set
yeah well I've been
um I guess people could say I've been
pretty
um have said a lot about my experiences
on set with him
I I never really experienced anything to
me it was more things that I witnessed
and then obviously the Wardrobe fitting
situation and the goo pop the green goo
pop and things like that okay well okay
so what was the Wardrobe situation
he would be in the wardrobe fittings
with all the young girls changing it was
just me I don't know I honestly don't
know because like wardrobe fittings you
would just be one-on-one with like the
Wardrobe person and then Dan in this
situation but it was like a small
trailer and it would just be like a
little curtain and he would just always
be on the other side like to the point
where I would hear the chair like
creaking if even breathed basically when
I was on the other side
um and now looking back at that
it doesn't seem right because I never
experienced that ever again that was
only a Dan
experience yeah I can't imagine what
valuable input he would have did he ever
give input on the outfits or was just
sitting there he he would give inputs no
he would give him and he would also want
the Polaroids oh that's foul that's foul
yeah yeah no he he took the Polaroid
that's that's yeah that's a problem and
then what was the problem you talked
about the goo what about the goo thing
oh God man this is just that's how the
bit this Business Insider article
literally started with what I said about
the goo I don't even think I can say
this on YouTube honestly
um but basically there was an episode
where I was supposed to be trying to
open this goo pop and I couldn't open it
and then at some point it opens and it
lands on Zoe's face
and instead of just having like it
naturally happen and have it land
wherever they ended up having like the
prop person the art Pro I don't know our
production person end up getting a
syringe and aiming it in a very specific
place that Dan wanted and if you look
back at that footage it doesn't sit
right
um and after it landed on her face I
mean there was an uproar of laughter all
the guys and boys were laughing laughing
and then I ended up hearing one of the
boys actually say what it reminded him
of and at that point I didn't even know
what the hell that even meant so I was
just trying to like I guess smile along
and no idea what was going on and then
watched it later on in my life and was
like oh that's why they were laughing
hysterically and oh this was an adult
joke joke
exploitation happening to a a minor at
the time on set I I haven't seen the
clip but I have it is it okay if I pull
it up sure I'll watch it first and then
I'll see if I think it's appropriate to
show the people
yeah we'll see about that oh I mean
I think it's fine to show
okay oh you think you have to worry
about claims
I mean it's so short golly that'd be
crazy if it got claimed
I mean here it is this also happened in
Victorious they had like his others like
this but it was with lotion like a
teacher was like hitting a lotion bottle
and it went on Trina's like face and
that was one of his other shows right
yeah it was his later show
oh he does this kind of stuff yeah so
can you pull that clip I'd be curious so
here here it is and all the clips yeah
here it is don't people saying don't
play I mean it's it's fine it's safe for
work
10 million kids saw it apparently
10 million put it out like that all I do
is squeeze a little like this
and so he was very specific about how
that shot was gonna be done yes
yes and the sad part is like all the
adults were laughing along with him and
there's just a child there not really
understanding like you can even see on
her face like she's trying to like
understand why she should be laughing
too maybe
that's so wild
so it one thing that strikes me about
the Dan Schneider thing is like um
there must have been other adults on set
that knew that he was doing
inappropriate things and right you as an
adult looking back it must feel like
that
yes I mean if I saw half of the [__]
that was going on on set now like at 31
I mean I would be walking off of set to
be quite honest with you I mean it was
it was so inappropriate at times you're
just like but no one ever said anything
huh no one right no this guy would
literally be like requesting massages
from the Wardrobe women oh yeah yeah and
you'd be in this tent like
you know sweating getting massages from
the women on set it was just crazy that
was back during the days when Harvey
Weinstein and all these big time
Hollywood people could just
they they felt untouchable right I mean
he was huge in the Nickelodeon Empire
completely I mean apparently there was
even a lawsuit uh I think allegedly uh
during the Amanda Bynes show where you
know he was doing just that and someone
literally sued
um the whole situation and you know 20
years later he was still doing it it
just goes to show you that the networks
are just as you know complicit
in these uh predatory
men Behavior types right unfortunately
it I don't think these Predators would
survive honestly if it wasn't for the
protection these like enablers around
them powerful enabling 100 I think when
we look back on all these powerful men
that that fell a lot of them were yeah
just being totally protected by the
network because they were making them a
ton of money they were burying
accusations they were bearing lawsuits
settling lawsuits they knew they knew
that these dudes were scum
they had it in the budget they would
actually have it in the budget to like
wow for hush hush money wow Etc like I
mean there's even a situation where wmg
was like literally in mentioned in the
ndas you know and you're just like
that's just doesn't sit right with me
you know here is the wholesome and uh
super not creepy Dan Schneider Ward
I mean every image of him honestly sadly
is just that you know it's it's pretty
there's no like normal photo of him I
guess New York Times tried to do like a
whole spread of him where he was trying
to look normal and whatever but even him
normal was just awkward this is as
normal as I can find him oh God why is
he always doing like a a choke hold
right he's holding her so tight like
loosen the grip why yeah like why do you
need to hold like what let go she also
you can tell she wants him kind of to
let go you know what I mean so here's
the other one and I'm guys if you if you
don't want to watch it just look away
I'm gonna open the lotion I don't I've
never seen this one so so I to me I just
I kind of want to know the context of
everything I think it's but again if you
don't want to watch it I'm about to show
it now so fair warning this is from
Victorious
what the [__] was that it with that that
was it huh he does it more he does it
more no he doesn't he goes in for
another one
she just has the lotion on her face
oh that there was no need for that oh
that's [__] up that's so foul dude
yo it's like Danny elfman's situation
have you heard about Jenny Elfman no
apparently he like sent allegedly
um bodily fluids in a cup to someone who
was working for him and his uh his
defense right now is that it was
Cetaphil
what is he uh I'm I'm looking up I'm
trying to This Is Halloween oh Oingo
Boingo
dude he's nightmare or whatever Before
Christmas
so he sent someone a car okay all right
Danny yeah these I know Danny Elfman and
he's also allegedly an elf man literally
which I mean I don't believe that for a
second
um so Dan Schneider eventually he as
these rumors started to circulate I
guess he Nickelodeon was forced to fire
him and he's been disgraced right
I no one can find him really I mean he's
um he's gone missing man I haven't heard
from him no one's heard from him he some
guy who I don't know Steve something
Hicks who apparently was a former uh
president at Nickelodeon made some kind
of Defense statement for him that was
just creepy and weird but Dan Schneider
is just honestly nowhere to be found he
just I hate to say it but I know where
he is where he's got to be in Thailand
Thailand or southeast Asia somewhere
where he can act out his sick [__]
fantasies
oh my that's literally where every old
creepy white dude moves it's true
actually I when I went to Thailand it
was pretty wild how many like German and
random just white dudes I saw her there
me and ILO went there uh a while ago
walking through Bangkok so many
white old white dudes walk cruising by
themselves yes
and they look like they're by themselves
and they look like
I don't know what a p word necessarily
looks like but if I had this it's them
yeah but it's the it is them they look
just like that I know exactly I
experienced the same thing when I went
to uh Thailand as well so he's there I'm
sure Dan's just fitting in yeah he's
there
so um was there anything else that
happened on said I didn't hit uh I don't
know much about it I'm interested
um I mean honestly
it was more also what happened
afterwards
um after I was working for Nickelodeon
when I saw a clip of Ariana Grande
um
that Dan Schneider
allegedly filmed and created and it was
so it was just so out of line and that's
actually what triggered a lot of my
memories like you know you just kind of
block that stuff out when you know
you're a kid I think like you're just he
was such an abusive person too like I
don't know if you heard but you know
that's why I left Nickelodeon was
because of his verbal abuse and what was
kind of opening up to kids yeah yeah
what kind of stuff would he would he
tell you
um well he just ended up bringing me
into a room at Nickelodeon and just like
degrading me and saying that the show
wasn't called Zoe 101 I mean it wasn't
called it was called what's it called
Nicole 101 it was called Zoe 101 and I
need to know basically my place here
um and it was just a very traumatic
experience I was crying in the chair and
it was like the last time that I could
honestly deal with that type of
situation with him and that's set
environment and after that I just ran
out like you know crying to my mom and I
was like I never want to see these
people uh again and she she took me
right out of there wow and we basically
thank you yeah thanks to my mom honestly
it's pretty mature for a kid to come I
feel like to come to that conclusion
yes I mean I got put through the ringer
on that show it was a pretty bad
um
three years I would say of my life yeah
Jamie Lynn Spears was just
created a very toxic unhealthy work
environment so I I want to ask you about
the Jamie Spears thing but when you were
in the office with Dan was it just the
two of you
it wasn't it was actually a whole bunch
of other execs at Nickelodeon and that's
why I ended up protesting Nickelodeon oh
yeah it was like five adults was there
anyone advocating for you in there or is
it just you it was just me so first they
had my mom in there
um and then I was very upset obviously
and they said like maybe it's best if
you just have like a one-on-one
conversation with Alexa here was
actually happening maybe she'll feel
more comfortable or whatever oh yeah
super manipulative my mom calls the
agent like my agent and she's like well
you know Alexa goes in for auditions all
the time anyways alone you know like
what what bad could happen
so I end up going in there alone and
that's when
that's when he really just went to town
on
little version of me that is so sad I
feel like on set maybe I'm being
optimistic but I'd be surprised to see
kind of that stuff happening like a
little girl going in the room by herself
with a bunch of Executives to get
grilled I mean it sounds so [__] up it
it was it honestly was that's why I mean
I'm never putting obviously my child in
the entertainment industry that that
experience alone just really
kind of scarred me for life
um and honestly he's not the creepiest
person in Hollywood but he definitely is
uh one of them right definitely one of
them right
well yeah who's your number one you have
someone in mind who's like King creeper
I I always I like to always think about
Brian uh
singer he's he's like the creepiest dude
oh yeah Brian Singer yeah I never met
him never had any experiences with him
but yeah no isn't it you're not his type
no no I'm not his type I am not I got
through in the clear on that one yeah
you might you may have been invited to
one of his hot tub parties if you were
uh yeah it's I mean this is the sad part
is like honestly it's gotten better you
know because they're a little bit more
afraid maybe of getting called out but
it hasn't really changed you know that
much I would say like I'm still hearing
you know things are happening which is
pretty upsetting you would they're just
also better at cleaning up now too like
the they're just better at
that I hate to hear
um what was the Ariana Grande thing you
were yours you were was that the feet
thing
yes and it's like her on the edge of the
bed
um pouring water
on her as a as a teenage girl and it's
like just very webcam-esque
um underage girl and there's even a
point where she's like squeezing the
potato and asking it to give her juice
and yeah it's just it's so out of line
like that's what really upsets me too
because apparently Nickelodeon also
approved of that allegedly and it's just
like well why are all these people
around I mean there's so many adults
around wouldn't someone at some point go
hey you know this looks like this or
this is giving me this kind of feel and
I think it's ex you know those kids
being exploited right that's what I
wonder too but I guess people are just
they're keeping their mouth shut because
it's like they just want to keep their
jobs
okay so I have this clip if you guys uh
don't want to watch it once again
I encourage you to not watch it it is
just a clip from a kid show I mean
you can't be that bad right
oh there's no audio I guess on this
you can bring it up it's okay no one
would ever say that why because if you
are soaking wet and you were upset about
it the last thing you'd want is for
somebody to bring you the ocean because
the ocean is even more wet than even the
wettest person in the world have you
ever tried to get your whole big toe in
your mouth
oh yeah I saw this
and so apparently apparently he has like
a foot thing right
yeah yeah allegedly
there's no reason for that I'm a Potato
no
[Music]
is it possible for a teenage girl to
drink water upside down
um thirsty
that's too much not possible
foreign
that's too much it's so [__] much man
it's out it's it's so out of line it's
it's it blows my mind
it blows my mind and I guess that's why
he's in Thailand now and no one can find
him
whoa whoa whoa there's there's old
I have some of his old erased tweets oh
yeah you've never seen these no here's
Dan Schneider video would you like to
see Victoria Justice pour ketchup all
over her feet well here you go
it's not enough that he's doing it he
needs to share it with all of his
friends it's ridiculous and it's called
The Slap
like why is it called The Slap
what any other names to choose man
that's not creepy and violent here's
another one pick Carly tickles Sam's
very unusual toes the [__] did you
describe her toes
if you have a moment will you please
name Sam's toes for us
what grown man writes like this anyway
please tell me
I want to know who I mean some dude
who's living in Thailand some dude
that's living in Thailand and fitting
fitting right in
there's so many of them he asked kids
around like the oh no
yes this is he made Sam and Cat I used
to watch that show
did you really
yeah it was a cartoon right wait no okay
I'm thinking of dog cat dog cat dog I
never watched Santa look at this tweet
Sam and Cat tomorrow right on the bottom
of your foot take a picture and use
hashtag Sam and Cat Saturday and we'll
retweet and follow until our fingers get
sore why the [__] and I mean I mean I
mean yeah I'm just gonna yeah you could
all the responses are kids feet with
markers on the bottom it's so [__]
vile
like what would be the purpose of that
oh here's salmon cat
yeah I I didn't know anything about Sam
and Cat
that's and that's Ariana Grande and
Jeanette McCurdy and actually that's Jim
McCurdy is I mean I I called out
a little bit of my personal experience
with Dan Schneider in 2019 and then when
Jeannette McCurdy came out with her book
and I heard you know those allegations I
was like okay you know enough is enough
and no one listened I mean when it was a
book all of a sudden people were paying
attention but when it was me just like
you know on my Instagram live obviously
no one there was no media that gave
really an honest [__] about about it
whatsoever and so yeah that's her book
is really what drove me as a mom
honestly to Nickelodeon
has Ariana Grande ever spoke about this
stuff publicly no she hasn't no but he
um
Dan Schneider tried to get me to you
know basically sign an NDA in 2019. oh
recently yeah yeah I was like I was
living in Palm Springs at the time and
it was so strange I was having a glass
of wine I was just chilling on the couch
and my boyfriend at the time was working
at Ace Hotel in Palm Springs and he
texted me and says hey there's some
lawyer calling him and messaging him
looking for me I was like what I thought
it was a scam he's like no it seems it
seems legit like they they want to get
into contact with you I said cool it's
all via text message I was like can you
send can you send their contact info
over and he did and so I called
and it was some random dude who answered
and I was like hi you know it's Lex
Nicholas apparently you're looking for
me and here I am and he goes oh hi this
is you know so and so and I represent
Schneider's Bakery and I hadn't heard
that name in such a long time like I was
taken aback like what is Schneider's
Bakery Schneider's Bakery is his
production company that's what he named
it okay yeah yeah not creepy at all
um so yeah and I was like okay
um yes like what what do you want
basically and then he goes into saying
if I was speaking to any documentary
filmmakers about my personal experience
with Dan and I was honestly there were
some people who were poking around and I
was having a few
um interactions with them and so I was
honest I was like well I wasn't honest
eventually I said it's really none of
your business but yeah but still none of
your business and he goes well I would
like to know what you're telling them
and I said well that's definitely I bet
you would [__] yes
it's like and
only not going to be going to be telling
you at all yeah um like Dan's like on
the three-way call
um and so I said no I'm you know I don't
feel comfortable doing that and then he
goes to say well Dan and I would like to
have you come into a room
um once again it's like listen I've been
into a room with Dan Schneider let me
tell you I'm never going into a room
with Dan Schneider again
um but he said we like to come up with
some type of agreements together and if
you're open to that
um we are basically and I
I was just like
um first of all you're representing a
[__] creep and I wouldn't come up
with any type of agreement with this
creep so no I'm not coming in and doing
this uh weird ass agreement with you
guys and he's like well if you change
your mind you know you could always call
me back it's like I will not be changing
my mind and please do not call me again
and I hung up the phone
um and now you know fast forward all of
it did end up coming out
which is wild but this was this is while
it was starting to build
um and so I in my personal experience I
don't think I was the only person to get
a phone call from Dan Schneider's lawyer
so I don't know how many people he was
successful with you know right that's
that's a good point I mean now because
when people started to feel more
comfortable coming out right there's got
to be a few people who probably you know
took the money and why not right I mean
you know at the end of the day I can't
judge anybody for for taking that route
either
no I mean honestly you don't even
there's so many uh the power Dynamic
alone you know you just can't blame the
person on the other end of that
especially if you need the money and
he's like here's a hundred thousand
dollars just to sign this paper and not
talk about me
I know wow so he knew he was cooked if
he was calling everybody up yeah he was
calling me up and
um I uh
that was the last time I heard from uh
Dan Schneider's team Dan when did he
disappear
he disappeared right around that
Business Insider
article
wow just he bailed apparently they got a
whole bunch of statements where I think
it was from like Imaginary Friends of
Dan
um that were there to defend him but off
the Record like wouldn't say their names
and anytime that's happening I'm just
sorry but I don't know if I can honestly
Buy
that there was really anyone defending
pairs though too yeah even if they are
real it's like okay true it's true
you're not in one of his you're not his
Target
so uh moving moving past the Dan
Schneider thing I am curious about what
you were beginning to touch on with
Jamie Spears Britney Spears sister was
one of your co-stars right
yes
yeah Jamie was Zoe Oh So Jamie Spears
was the main character of this show and
you were playing like her best friend
yeah and her roommate okay
and I understand that you guys had some
conflict on set
we did
um I I still don't really understand
what the conflict was exactly but she
just didn't seem to really uh
like me from from day one
um the first day that I met her you know
I went up to her I remember and just
being super excited and I was a very
bubbly
uh young girl like very talkative a
little bit like my character Nicole
definitely it's probably why I got the
role it wasn't hard for me to play her
um and she was just very
uh taken aback by my personality I think
and just kind of gave me the cold
shoulder and I just thought you know
what honestly maybe she's shy
um also maybe she's experienced a whole
bunch of different people coming up to
her just for the fact that she's Britney
Spears sister so at first I wasn't
really taking it personally but I did
notice it right away and then it just
slowly
escalated where there was no interaction
between her and I she wouldn't even
respond to me she wouldn't even sit with
us at lunch sometimes I wasn't invited
to go sit with them at lunch in her
trailer and it just it just started to
snowball basically and then it became
bullying where she would just say harsh
things you know to me like why do you
smile so much you know like this kid
bully right um [__] basically and but if
you know at that time it hurt
um I was a kid it sounds like not only
didn't it hurt but it almost
seems like other people on set
yeah we're kind of
forced to
go along with her like when you say you
went in the office and got Brett said
and Dan Schneider was like you're not
Zoe yeah that sounds like something that
probably was he was influenced by James
something Jamie said yeah the culture is
definitely that's why you know whoever
is the first person on the call she you
know especially back then there was that
power Dynamic
um and that was kind of the person who
everyone didn't want to get on their bad
side basically and so she kind of
created the culture of the set and
her not liking me made everyone else
kind of feel like I think they had to
also engage in that type of behavior and
so it was just but it was sad because I
just wanted to be friends with everybody
and it was just it was just this wall
um to the point where they ended up
getting rid of one of the girls on the
show in the first season because of the
bullying experience so she was doing
this to other people as well well no
this girl was actually doing it with her
to me and so why did she leave
she got I mean they let her go because
she was so mean yeah it was like it was
creating she pushed me into a rock at
one point in one of the episodes what
the heck and yeah it got like it was it
was just really bad it was it sucks like
it was just not a good time honestly and
so yeah they ended up having to let her
go and that's when they hired Victoria
Justice for the second season and I was
stoked about that because
strangely enough her mom dated my dad my
uncle like when they were in college so
there was like some kind of connection
and so I thought that that was going to
make the culture different on set
because maybe me and Victoria would
actually be friends you know and that
would create a different environment and
it did actually like she we were best
friends for the for the better half of
the second season and then
all the girl Dynamic culture mean girls
situation ended up happening again with
her and Jamie to the point where
that's when the Britney Spears
experience happened so because you're
saying that Victoria
was both was getting in trouble with
Jamie or that they were yeah bowling so
they were they were going mean yeah so
at one point
like Victoria and I were totally fine
and then I don't know what happened I
think it was like literally a boy
conversation like I remember it being
something so teenage girl about a boy
and then I show up to Seth the next day
and I remember opening up the makeup
trailer and seeing you know Victoria
like turn around and like laugh and then
whisper into Jamie's ear and they were
like laughing it was like so horrible
hippos yeah so and it ridiculous it
sounds silly but I know it's so painful
when you're that it is yeah it's so
painful you think the whole world is
against you really you know so does
anyone like me it's hard and so you know
and you're on set and you can't in those
environments you're not allowed to be
human
like kids weren't allowed to be human
you were supposed to be professional and
professional basically meant robotic you
know you weren't you don't want to ruin
the set Vibe
um and so you had to hold it all in
which was really hard for me and so that
ended up happening and it escalated the
last like two and a half weeks of the
second season
to the point where that's when Brittany
ended up coming on to the set so I
understand this kind of all culminated
when Britney Spears someone that you
were a big fan of yes Jamie's sister
came on set and she had heard from her
sister about you know what a terrible
person you were and and she screamed at
you on set is that right in the trailer
in the trailer so so there was this guy
named Ian who was our talent coordinator
and sometimes you know your parents
don't come with you always to and from
set or to and from makeup and hair there
would be a basically a talent
coordinator who was your guardian that
actually him and the school teacher they
would be like your Guardians if your
parents weren't there on set and so Ian
came to the trailer and it was a typical
day he just said hey I'm gonna bring
Alexa to makeup and hair my mom said
okay fine I went with Ian I remember him
kind of acting a little bit strange as
we were walking and then he goes hey
Brittany Amy would like to talk to you
in the trailer
and a little bit of me was actually
kind of hopeful that maybe this that
Brittany was going to come in and it was
going to create some kind of mediation
and maybe Jamie was willing to sit down
and talk to me for once which is all I
ever wanted was just like a nice
conversation to understand one another
and so in that moment I'm thinking
Britney's gonna be that person I
couldn't imagine Brittany not being that
person at that time she was like an idol
you know like as a kid so I remember
going okay and then we went over to the
trailer and I remember knocking on the
door and then opening it and right when
I went to turn Ian like fled
he just disappeared so this guy's
looking out for your welfare and he just
tossed you to the Sharks 100 like that
and that happens a lot on these sets
like who's working for who really you
know sometimes you know you're just like
it was child endangerment 100 yeah
because his his interests are not
aligned with yours by by just by the
definition of his job it seems like no
was that was this the first time you met
Britney Spears no I mean she came on set
a few times so like I saw and she was
always really nice
um so that's why I really didn't think
anything was trained she was always so
friendly every time she was coming onto
set and that's why I always say like
imagine though if it wasn't thank God it
was just Britney Spears in that [__]
trailer you know what I mean thank God
it wasn't a predator
in that trailer you know that's how you
I started to think like wow that guy
just literally tossed me God only knows
what could have happened to me in that
trailer thank God it was just Britney
Spears thank god
um so yeah anyways I go into the trailer
and I just remember before I even hit
the last step Jamie runs to the back of
the trailer just like bails on on
whatever the hell is about to happen so
that's made me a little bit nervous but
I stepped in anyways and I remember I
stepped in and Britney comes beside me
and locks the trailer door
and she just starts she was about she I
think she was like eight months pregnant
at the time she was about me right now
so you you came in and then Brittany
locked the door behind you yeah that's
pretty ominous
it was it was freaky and but now when I
look back at it I know the whole you
know situation that was happening it it
makes sense but it still obviously
wasn't okay none of that was okay that
happened but it makes a lot more sense
now than it did then then it was just
really really really really scary and so
I remember she just started yelling at
me
um telling me that I was bullying her
sister and I wanted to say something and
my I just remember like literally
feeling my throat you know just closed I
couldn't even I had no I couldn't even
speak and I tried and I just started to
cry and like hyperventilate
um and she was like I'm gonna make sure
you don't work again
and that's wild I was like oh my God
Britney Spears hates me you know and as
a kid that now even made it so much
worse you know now I have this this Idol
of mine at that age also now just hating
my guts and there's no one there
protecting me Ian bailed on me my mom
doesn't even know where I am and it was
really really [__] scary I just
remember
tunnel vision mode and try like going
back to the door because I fell a little
bit backwards to like the couch area and
I remember getting up and just trying to
find the door and then realizing it was
locked again and having to unlock it and
then once I opened the door I puked oh
my God I just I was it was so much you
know for my like did they see I wonder
did Britney see you puke yeah no
definitely I mean I
no one said and no one cared they're
like that's normal
yeah this little girl just puked from
being bullied and stressed and like
tortured yeah yeah
and I ran ran to my trailer I remember
and you know for a mom like when I came
in my mom was just like what the [__]
you know I'm hyperventilating I just
puked I run to the toilet and I'm like
in literally in fetal position just like
rocking myself basically just being like
I can't even explain I remember her
screaming just saying what happened like
please just tell me what happened I
could have been I was in total shutdown
mode
um and I just remember my mom opening
the trailer door and screaming like Dan
and like anyone and like Ian and no one
came for about
10 to 15 minutes and she was like
screaming they would have heard her yeah
oh yeah it was like a mom scream you
know like Mama Bear like it's like
everyone and maybe in Mars they heard
you know she was so loud they were
probably getting their story straight
before they came and talked to you guys
you're totally right because this is a
liability liability liability and we
have to protect Jamie totally
totally and Britney's gone she left in
the car
um and so I just remember
hearing the trailer kind of move and
people were coming up the steps and here
comes Dan Schneider
with his sunglasses and he looks at me
and I'll never forget this he goes now
what
huh
yeah
he said now what and how did you
interpret that to mean at the time
everything's my fault oh he was like
he's like now now another thing with you
kind of thing yes yeah
and so I was like for 15 minutes what an
[__] uh-huh total [__] and I just
remember I wasn't able for the first
time ever I'm a pretty talkative person
and I was I couldn't say anything and
um I just remember looking at him and
then my mom's screaming at him and
saying like you know Alexa's not going
back onto set he goes one moment and he
leaves the trailer and he comes back 10
minutes later with one of those freaking
you know like those DVD players back in
the day that were like those portable
ones with the screen and then you would
just put the DVD in yeah he literally
comes back with one of those and he's
like here
like as if that was like the trade as if
that was gonna make me I remember
holding the box he was giving it to you
like take this you shut up [__]
it was so weird and like the lamest gift
also like what the [__] is this I
remember looking at it just going am I
supposed to say thank you you know and
my mom was livid and she's like I'm not
putting my daughter in the set and he
goes oh yes you are like we have to get
this last shot and contact contractually
Alexa has to go back on set
and I remember just kind of looking at
all the adults
on the floor I was on the floor I
remember just looking up at them and
just you know
I didn't matter that much in that
situation and sure enough I had to go
back
on to set and there's even a clip that
someone found it made it into the edit
where the girls literally pushed me
shoved me on camera yeah like it went
viral in Tick-Tock actually oh [__] it
ended up being yeah you guys should find
it it's wild like and then someone like
posted and was like holy [__] like this
is for real you can actually see it's
happening while they're filming and so I
had to go back on set and get bullied
more
and humiliated more by everyone and that
was my last day on the set of uh Zoe 101
and by quitting the show did they like
come after you financially or were they
a pain in the ass or were they easy
no they they were easy because I think
they were really afraid of
the liability on the other end you know
like technically there was child
endangerment that happened there was a
lot of things that happened that weren't
supposed to happen you know under their
care and so I think that's when they try
to hold on for a minute I remember and
then they accept it and I'll never
forget you want to know the punishment
go ahead they had to add one more like
cherry on top of the sundae they said
you know we're letting Alexa go but just
tell her she is banned from Every Kid's
Choice Awards oh no not the Kids Choice
Awards
still that's so scummy like they're like
they're like how do I hurt this kid more
no ice cream ever again
crazy
these were adults saying [__] like that
I'll never forget that I went okay at
the same time I was like I don't need to
go to the Kids Choice Awards again like
all right but also what a weird thing to
add to the whole thing so uh I guess
fast forward to modern times I think
this was somewhat recently uh Britney
Spears actually took to Twitter to make
uh a really beautiful apology to you
right which was which was actually
um wow really incredible to read
it was incredible to read for me as well
honestly it's the only apology I've ever
gotten in Hollywood
um which is really sad to say and also
kind of remarkable and amazing that it
was Britney Spears right who um
apologized I will she mentioned me once
and defended me and I remember she said
you know you lied just like you lied
about Alexa Nicholas and that I remember
reading that on Instagram and just being
like what is this it was like healing
all these wounds
oh sorry I think I found that clip did
you think so
are you watching Zoey 101 trying to see
some evidence of Nicole I'm trying to
zoom in hold on let me see if I can get
a closer look get in there
kind of bullied on the show mind you 100
believe her I'm just looking for some
Clues so I want you guys to pay
attention to Quinn and Victoria
right here boom and let's slow-mo this
so you guys can see the hit in the head
and then you see Quinn push her arm
even further like why why this girl was
actually bullied on this show y'all and
they want to reboot it no
yeah you can see my actual like real
life uh real that was an acting my
reaction I gotta watch this again so
which one you're watching which person
are you here see some evidence I'm in
the pink right there next to the guy so
I'm like the brunette not here but I'm
just looking for some Clues not here
there in the blue skirt yeah okay okay
right here
and let's slow-mo this so you guys can
see the hit in the head and then you see
Quinn push her arm even further like why
why this girl was actually bloody
bullied on this show y'all and they want
to who's the girl that hit you
yeah Aaron Aaron Sanders she played
Quinn she was just going along with the
culture at the end like
I I don't know what happened there but I
do remember that those last you know
couple of uh I guess like weeks
um she was kind of feeling invited into
the girl's Circle and that's like what
sucks about the culture there is
everyone wanted to feel you're a kid you
want to be seen you want to be
appreciated you want to be loved and so
any of that that was happening kids were
willing to not be the best versions of
themselves just to receive being seen
um and so that kind of happened there
towards the end with Aaron but Aaron
wasn't really someone who participated
much in the whole bullying
um with me but towards the end there was
a little bit of that and you can see I'm
shocked like I turn around yeah you know
I'm like why are you hitting my and that
would they would that episode was the
Britney Spears week and that was the
last scene I think I ended up doing and
they would literally get the the squirt
guns and they were trying to get it in
my eye and like laughing at me God
that's horrible man Harley it's like
being forced to be with your bullies
like I feel like we've all experienced
bowling to some degree in school and
just how bad it feels you're being
forced to spend all day with them all
day and also like you're getting paid
it's like a weird right you know what I
mean as a kid like it's like you're
getting paid and then you're having to
deal with them and you don't want to you
don't want to be seen as problematic and
you get told as a kid if you speak up
too much you know you might not work
again
so you have these weird pressures that
just you know you I don't think you
necessarily have in high school it's a
different type of it's more yeah yeah do
you mind if I read this um this
uh tweet from Brittany yeah sure so here
I'm just going to read it it's not super
long but I thought it was really nice
this is after her falling out with her
family
yes so she's like oh my sister is like
not the best her sister kind of sucks
and I think it was probably well she she
talks about in the letter I'll just read
it it broke my heart to see your
interview about your experience in the
business Hollywood is a place of dreams
but let's be honest on rare occasions do
people come out years later and share
the dark side
there are thousands of people with
broken dreams and I'm absolutely in awe
of you raising awareness for the next
Generation on how to be protected the
one thing you said you wish you could
have told your younger self is that you
wish you could have known you could have
just walked away I find that really an
interesting insight there mm-hmm you
would have left sooner that's like
you're looking back yeah yeah
countless times I did the same thing and
I took the abuse it's nice to know I'm
not the only one who has felt that way I
know it's 15 years later what you are
sharing but trust me I know it still
matters although I have apologized to
you personally just by Instinct my heart
at the time didn't know how incredibly
good my family was at the acting
language
just imagine me
visiting my little sister on set last
day of shooting bringing sprinkle
cupcakes nine months pregnant hormone
raging like hell and the assistant
director Ian Witnesses Jamie Lynn
running to me placing her hands on my
knees while I'm sitting down her sobbing
telling me that she's just been bullied
on set
the assistant director my mom included
in the room were just silent my sister
was literally like my daughter growing
up so I apologize for my ignorance for
yelling at you when I obviously had no
idea what was really going on Jesus
Christ I was pregnant and let's be
honest all these moms and dads the
watchful white owls Who hide behind the
scenes observing their children Stars
referring to my mother who should have
immediately stepped in and took over the
situation and I told my my nine month
pregnant self to sit down relax and have
a Sprinkle cupcake
they should have treated me like a guest
because that's exactly what I was it's
always been extremely interesting the
situations my family has put me in to
make me embarrassed I know you have
probably heard what happened to me three
years ago I wrote three different
versions of a book and since then
honestly it's been the hardest thing
I've ever had to do and if you haven't
heard already it's become a joke because
TMZ says I'm running out of paper
I'm also sure they get a good laugh at
seeing me on my Instagram what was done
to me is frankly beyond all the way you
spoke gave me strength and inspiration I
do write you the special day because I'm
sorry for ever hurting your feelings you
should tell Nickelodeon to kiss your ass
that
I get the feeling that Brittany uh did
understand when she said I know it was
15 years ago but I know it still matters
and that's that's yeah that probably
ringed true for you right very much so
yeah because especially as a survivor of
you know essay you know I'm not even the
bully stuff a lot of the time you get
backlash of this happens you know x
amount of time
um like Justin Long loved to remind me
you know how many decades ago it was
um and I think survivors get that a lot
you know and when you're a sensitive
person you get that a lot like why this
was so long ago why does this matter to
you you know move on basically so to
hear someone understand that you know
your feelings are valid
um it's okay that it still hurts and
it's okay that there's still a wound
there I think all of us deserve to hear
that like all of our feelings of sadness
are honestly should be validated in some
way
um so that that was really that was big
for me that was like I never expected
that right and um
it made me feel very good very
validating because I'm sure there's
probably a lot of people like oh she's
lying about everything yes oh every yeah
that happens that happens a lot with me
um that's what Marty singer whatever
Jonah Hill's lawyer you know you're a
Serial accuser right I remember he said
that about you oh that Britney Spears
statement is like yo that should happen
yeah that was really good that she did
that was that a healing moment for you
it was very healing for me
um I cry even when you were reading it
now because if it feels very good
it feels feels very good I would hope
that my kids you know got to experience
that from someone that bullied them
because it's intense when someone
bullies you Britney Spears too yes yeah
and she under you know I think I we both
have seen some dark sides of
our industry and
um I think she's also commendable
because she's also spoken out in ways
that
um has inspired me to do the things that
I'm doing like we eat Predators honestly
a lot of that strength came from reading
a lot of Britney Spears you know
Instagram
um captions about how she was going up
against a lot of these powerful
um institutions that were representing
her at the time like TriStar Etc I was
like whoa I've never seen that before
especially a woman you know so you're
like damn have you ever connected
she dm'd me oh that's good
yeah she first DM me personally before
she did it publicly that's nice that's
really nice yeah it was really nice and
I was fine with that I didn't share it
obviously with any you know I didn't put
it anywhere I just loved that she did
that and then about a month later is
when she then made it public that's
that's that's great that's really good
she did that yeah it's a nice happy yeah
there's one happy ending in Hollywood
yeah so I wanna I guess you mentioned
Jason long who is Justin Long or Justin
long I was like who the [__] is this guy
because I recognized the name is this
guy
this is the [__] guy and this and now
that I'm gonna I'm gonna transition a
bit to the Jonah Hill anecdote you
shared okay so you were partying and how
old were you at the time that this
happened dude honestly I don't know if I
was 16 yet
so you I might I might have been 15
turning 16. okay so were you working on
Zoe or was this after this was after and
so were you still were you still trying
to work were you still trying to be I
was working you were working I was
working non-stop I was doing like a more
drama like you know cold cases and csis
and
um shows like that so they did not in
fact uh make sure you never worked again
I worked again no Brittany didn't end up
canceling me
yeah
it sounded like some of the producers
wanted to though they did and I ended up
getting a little bit canceled later it's
a little bit harder for me now to put um
a foot into the industry after a lot of
my advocacy work to be honest with you
yeah yeah I can see that for some
um so yeah it's worth it so of course
you're doing the right thing what's
better than that yeah nothing being rich
famous uh no I'm just kidding I mean I
mean it would be nice to get paid for
you know doing the good things yeah yeah
it would be nice huh
um so so you're at Justin Long's house
you're friends with him how did you end
up over at his house
it was the first time okay so
I I was actually filming my show last
night I have the show coming out called
e-proders daily
um and I was explaining a little bit of
the story but basically what happened
was I was hanging out with my friend I'm
not gonna disclose her name obviously
for privacy reasons she had a like a
nice BMW Z3 convertible and we were
driving on outpost and I remember she
wanted to go and hang out with the tool
bag Predator from CSI Miami Jonathan
Togo or something I I don't know what
the hell his name is but anyway she was
this guy hooking up with this guy so
yeah so that guy because that was
Justin's roommate okay
and and what was he doing at the time
the CSI stuff no yeah he was doing CSI
Miami okay
which by the way I ended up being on
I'll say a bit of that
interaction afterwards
um but anyways she was seeing him at the
time but she was underage
and like I think he was like almost 30.
so that was back wait how old is he
I don't know I think he was like in his
I think Justin was around his mid-20s
when he was 45 now so yeah that tracks
yeah so they were a lot older so he was
a lot older
a lot older and so she was seeing him I
think she was 16 or 17. Justin is also
45 now so they were like these are like
men grown ass men they were grown as men
said you were telling that story I was
imagining you guys were kind of
contemporaries but that's not the case
not no no no no not at all I was like 15
turning 16 and then they were all like
you know living in a duplex in LA and
like had established careers okay
um and so yeah so I remember we were on
the way to his place and she was like
they're inviting you over and while she
was like on the phone with them or
something we ended up getting a flat
tire on outpost and we had to pull over
and we didn't think we were going to be
able to go and then you know what the
dudes actually the Bros ended up telling
us they were like you can make it down
the hill it's only like 15 minutes down
just cruised down in neutral
they didn't even offer to come
I don't mean to laugh but it's like wow
you know looking back at that it's
[__] up so anyways they're like you
can make it and so we like made it dude
we went oh you did you cruise down in
neutral five miles okay that's badass
High medals per hour to get to this
place and to Justin Long Dong's place
and I'm like oh
and I was like okay so we're driving
it's like five miles per hour down
Outpost and I just hear the rim starting
I remember the rim was like hitting the
ground you know and you're like is this
worth it like is this is this word that
really wasn't worth it
um but we get to the bottom of the hill
we finally get to the place and we
arrive and nobody was there yet it was
actually just Justin and this Togo dude
um and I remember she went into the
bedroom with Togo and I was left in the
living room with Justin and so you're
you're saying that this third this 30
year old dude Togo was having a section
like a sexual relationship with your
underage friend which is sexual well
that's yeah and it's a statutory rape as
well yeah wow and oh yeah yeah oh and
just didn't do that there that was Nor
you have no idea why why would you even
do that like you can have sex with of
age girls why of age consensual yeah age
consensual yeah it's like why golly
you should hear the punked episode where
Justin's literally ordering a drink for
maybe a girl who's underage and he's
like yeah she's of age consensual it's
like bro he's
said that on camera it's like no you're
not getting accused of anything you're
bad literally it's ridiculous
anyways so I'm like in the living room
I'm talking to this guy remember he puts
a vinyl on
um he's that kind of guy in La which is
fine that's a lot of guys in L.A and so
he puts on the vinyl and I remember he
asked me if I wanted a drink I said yes
now we're starting to drink we're
talking
um drinks go by and then
people started to arrive a couple of
people and one of them was Jonah no
you're a 15 year old drinking have you
drank before this is something you're
used to doing
I drank like I would sneak out sometimes
my mom's like I could think that night
actually like my mom thought I was
sleeping over at you know a friend's
house but really I was out you know and
living in L.A
when you sneak out you can sneak out
into some serious trouble without your
parents knowing and so a lot of people
like to blame my mom but like my mom
really didn't know I was like a teenager
in Los Angeles with access to getting
into bars and clubs you know at that
time it was a really different it was
anyways that was that was La in like
whatever 2008. okay um all the bars
would let me in WoW crazy
never I deed me
so anyways Jonah comes in I remember he
starts like smoking weed like rolling a
joint or something and
um I'm sitting there I know kind of who
he is I honestly didn't know it him that
well because I think it was just super
bad it's like very early this is right
after super bad Jonah Hill I think so
when did that come out like it must have
been around the same time let me see
yeah it's like I feel like it was
as Superbad came out 2007. okay so yeah
it was like a year after so that was
movie was a big deal I mean I I remember
seeing that and thinking Jonah Hill was
awesome after that uh totally after that
came out yeah he was like kind of the it
kid during that time like accepted yes
and
by the way I I pulled this clip of uh
just getting the drink for the underage
girl get the of age consensual in there
let's see yeah
[Music]
of age consensual why did you say that
you weird little [__]
of age consensual yo what the [__] does
that mean bro hold on one more time
dude that's kind of insane that they set
him up to like commit a crime they did
and they're like yo will he buy these
underage girls alcohol was that the
experiment yeah he will and he did oh
dude that's cutthroat
yeah he did it well will Justin have sex
with this underage girl dude Jonah's
right next to him
I gotta hear this one more time
I'll just get one of these Asian pear
things hold on okay
I'll just get a Gray Goose
[Music]
wait was that Johnny next to him yeah
yes that's Jonah oh yeah you see what's
going on here he's he's under a bad
influence I hate to say it
yeah they're getting the Justin schlong
Hollywood
handbook
I'll just get a Gray Goose and cranberry
okay
I'll just get one of these did I miss it
again damn it I don't I think so wait no
I feel like
I feel like oh wait I have the time step
let me just pull that one up again
because I don't want to get claimed so
I'm trying to show as little as possible
ladies can I have you oh this is another
time stamp this is another time stamp oh
they come to ice listen yo they should
listen to this part though shows you how
different the world is now how we
perceive this stuff like at the time
this was just a funny joke right he was
trying to get these young girls drunk
like haha yeah even like films like
super bad that was the whole narrative
like we're gonna get these girls drunk
enough to sleep with us and like that
was it but this is real life but this is
real life this is him in real life
trying to get young girls drunk and it's
like just a silly joke like how we're
pranking you
and I was one of those girls wow you
were one of those girls in real life
all right I gotta this is nuts
but let's just say hypothetically
are you for real brother
let's just say hypothetically they don't
have IDs
bro so did that work back then
hey brother look the other way huh yeah
totally they're 15. so what
that doesn't work for me okay
how old are you
it tells them to say 21. it's close Okay
so waiting
how old are you
I'm 17.
okay Sarah do me a favor I want you to
go back there I want to get what you get
out of here
that's nuts the premise of this prank is
blowing my mind
dude and I didn't know about this so
This got sent to me the day after I
tweeted all of a sudden this video
resurfaced and I was watching and I'm
like this is how deep the patriarchy was
raining right in this time right you
know like that got approved by a network
yeah funny and even the crazy part is
even Justin long was like that's funny
you can put that out
totally and it's them together what are
the odds too it's like
very true it's kind of breaking my brain
very true
it broke my brain I I I my favorite
Ashton Kutcher prank was when he tried
to convince uh his good friends to go to
Jeffrey Epstein's Island
no no I'm kidding but like we're gonna
get on a flight with my friend Epstein
they call it the lalola ex the Lolita
Express you guys want to go
stuff everyone's like yeah dude I know
about him
dude who were the celebrities who would
they be
yeah just yeah Justin schlong Justin
Long dog yeah he um so yeah so you kind
of know what I'm dealing with now at
this point very much
um okay so that's where I'm at she you
know eventually comes out we all start
drinking they even make some kind of
jokes about our age I remember Jonah at
one point being like can you even drink
this like and he was like pulling it
away and then like brought you know put
it back to me and so it was like a joke
that we were underage they knew yeah oh
yeah clearly he was sitting like they
can't even deny it after that clip no he
was just sitting with
girls in a public setting and trying to
get them alcohol I mean hypothetically
hypothetically of course just dude she
never got the alcohol what do you want
hypothetically so yeah so anyways
hypothetically I was there
um drinking with them and they're making
jokes and then at one point I wanted a
cigarette
um and I didn't obviously have one
because I couldn't buy one legally
so Jonah ends up saying I have cigs like
but they're in the in my car
and I was like okay and I thought he was
gonna go and get it and he was like I
don't really want to go all alone if you
know what I mean like you know come with
me
and I remember being like all right you
know whatever like I trust I don't think
anything what could possibly [__]
happen you know between here and the and
the Prius
um with Jonah Hill and so we went
downstairs see his Prius the American
Spirits I remember were in the front
seat and he grabbed them and then we
were walking like awkwardly back to the
door and I remember saying like hey can
I have one
because we're outside and he didn't say
anything he just like slams me across
the door I'll never forget it
because you don't forget these things
um you like slammed me across the door
and he just put his tongue like right in
my mouth and it was like I just remember
moving around it was like really intense
and I just remember being like startled
and kind of just grossed out and I
pushed I tried to like push him away
um and I did actually he did end up
backing away and I remember turning
around and like running upstairs and the
guy who I first found up there was
ironically weirdly was the the emo dude
from Wedding Crashers I loved that movie
at the time so I remembered him and I
remember just having a conversation with
him just kind of like he I think he was
married at the time I think even his
wife was there they were like the only
people that is where things started
getting fuzzy like obviously I was
drinking but I remember him and I think
his wife was there and it was Justin and
it was Jonah and it was Togo and it was
my my underage friend
um and that was a story that I honestly
Lee my husband knows this story it was
like a story I told a lot of people
honestly and it
throughout time like when you're a
Survivor you start putting them kind of
on like a list of most traumatic you
know least traumatic you know when
you're going to therapy you have all
these things but there's they're
starting to create like an order to
things and Jonah was just one that I I
just never thought I was ever going to
tell that story publicly honestly it
wasn't something that I felt the need to
really go out and tell the world
um that story but when I woke up to
Sarah's Brave
um
screen captures of the experience that
she had with him it immediately
triggered me and you know I when I when
you get triggered a little bit is a
little bit impulsive and I got triggered
and I was like I know that no one else
is coming forward about anything about
him right now and I wanted to do that to
like support her and I didn't even know
if anyone's gonna see it honestly I
really did not think anyone was gonna
notice it was gonna get buried I thought
in the in all the tweets and about him
in boundaries how did how did you
process that at the time when he did
that to you was that kind of a normal
thing for you to happen or was that even
out of the ordinary
honestly man like I've been assaulted so
many times in the industry it's sad so
so pretty normal it was it was pretty
normal
it definitely stood out in my brain and
I remember being angry and like
um emotionally like I felt like a a
boundary was crossed to speak Jonah's
language a boundary felt like it was
crossed and you know that's how I felt I
what I wasn't you know you don't call
the cops like it wasn't that kind of era
first of all like they would be like why
the [__] are you out at 15 and like then
your mom's gonna be super upset it was
just you're a teenager so you're just
put into a situation where the only
thing to do is just quickly process it
um and then you know you end up really
processing it as an adult in therapy
later on which is what's been happening
to me now in my 30s did you guys talk at
all after that at the party or
no I stayed awake I did not like him
yeah I I didn't like that he didn't
apologized to me
um and that was also just pretty
upsetting you know he didn't say
anything about anything else that he was
accused of
and then he gets Marty singer like the
dude if you're gonna choose any lawyer
to defend you just don't have it be the
guy who defended like Danny Masterson or
whatever his name Marty singer yeah we
were I've
that's so funny that you mentioned his
name I won't say yeah
or maybe I should
yeah who cares who cares but I don't
want to be wrong here let me make sure
uh uh yeah be right okay here let me get
this right Marty singer Colleen
Ballinger
no it's his friend they work together oh
and so wait okay Andrew
brittler brettler yes yes yes so these
guys okay because I thought that Andrew
breitler reps some of those people you
mentioned they he does and they're
Partners Google yeah Google Marty singer
and Andrew whatever the hell his last
name is you'll see photos of them
together
Marty singer and Andrew breitler oh yeah
they're quite the duo
named to Hollywood reporter's power
lawyer list it's giving the uh
Harvey Weinstein uh
Kavanaugh pick that is okay listen
listen everybody needs a lawyer you know
what I mean I as a profession uh you
know I lawyers are scumbags they're all
scumbags the good ones and the bad ones
what do you want agreed but my my uh
Grandpa went to Harvard and he was a
lawyer and I'll never forget what he
said he said he was a criminal lawyer
criminal defense lawyer and he said I'll
represent anyone butter but a rapist
interesting and I'll never forget that
that he said that so there is
you've hit a line he had like a you know
what now I think you could you could say
hypothetically about Andrew brettler and
Marty singer yeah hypothetically they
don't have that line they do not but I
don't know that for sure because I don't
know the guilt or innocence of his of
his clients and stuff but certainly some
of his clients are accused of that well
Danny was convicted right yeah he was
actually so actually so then they do
defend rapists they do because he was
convicted he went to jail correct so I
think it's so it is fair to say that
Andrew breitler and Marty singer defend
rapists correct
yeah I would I would agree with you I'm
not going to debate on that let me just
make sure uh uh Andrew
what was it allegedly hypothetically
what was the guy's name from the
the Scientology rapist guy from the 90s
Danny Masters and Danny Masterson Mr
rapey oh he's that's Danny raperson
Danny raperson yeah that's that's his
real name legal name that's his
government yeah it's on his ID now let's
see okay so her her attorney is Andrew
brettler so I don't know if I don't know
if Marty singer no I wonder does Marty
singer have any um affiliation with
Brian Singer are they Brothers oh my you
know what because they have the same
last name
they're all in the same Circle dude
they're all in the same Circle I
wouldn't be surprised Ryan Singer and
Marty singer are they are they because I
just want to get my facts straight
I feel like their streams have crossed
yeah you know what I mean right there
okay okay this is all very interesting
yeah yeah well and allegedly and I don't
say this
I don't know nothing about nobody
yeah neither do those lawyers I don't
know nothing about them yeah Brian
Singer never met the guy never read
anything about him so everything I'm
saying right now is comedy it's parody
also I don't know anything about
anything I literally am the dumbest
person alive I'm a goldfish good call
you're a goldfish I have no memory I
have no thoughts I don't know anything
about anybody nobody takes what I say
seriously you're an impressive goldfish
I didn't realize I was having a
conversation with the Goldfish this
entire time what oh is this Dory say it
again yeah by the way here is this is
not real right cam you're [__] with
me
I'm a goldfish
this is not a real image I think we need
to say that this is not a real limit
yeah yeah that's a Photoshop it's too
real images yeah we Photoshop together
yeah yeah that's that didn't really look
that photoshop to me okay
um I wouldn't have been that shocked by
that photo if it was it would be good so
okay so Jonah Hill yeah Marty singer
yeah you're you're coming out really I
feel like gave a lot of weight to his
ex-girlfriends
original account
because what I saw there in first of all
that was really
um awesome which he did there just
because I don't I I've been emotionally
abused in relationships before but I'll
put like the really really bad physical
assaults or you know the sexual abuse
obviously in my brain more ahead of the
emotional abuse and like the emotional
abuse isn't something that I I
necessarily
um I don't know put a lot of weight to
sometimes and when I saw her put weight
to it and and wanted like it to be
validated that really put a lot into
perspective for me personally
um and I thought that was pretty badass
that she did that because when I was
reading those text messages what maybe
people don't understand if you're like
not a survivor of an abuser is that when
he was giving those boundaries that
power Dynamic first of all I think
they're like 10 years apart or whatever
so there's already like an age
difference there but also you love this
individual your brain chemistry is all
like oxytocin and out and you have this
person basically telling you that all
the things that make you you he doesn't
like those about you right and she was
that person when he met her
right and so all of a sudden you start
to be like are these things not lovable
about me should I change you know these
things so when she came forward what I
and what I saw as a Survivor was I think
when when we come forward as survivors
we're looking for validation because
we've been so gaslit that we want to
hear like can you please tell me if I'm
wrong or right you know like I I can't I
don't know anymore that's how it [__]
with your head so deeply that people
don't realize that like a lot of
survivors subconsciously are coming
forward I believe because they just need
to know what's happening to them or what
happened to them and that's when we go
to therapy you know like you go to
therapy to like understand what happened
to you pretty much or to process it and
I think coming forward is a very similar
experience it's just not in a room with
one individual it's a lot more intense
but you want the validation basically
and so I saw her wanting that validation
and and I know what that feels like
because I've come forward
um before and it's scary yeah and
especially when you're female people are
like get someone rich and famous yeah
and then you got all these bot Bros it's
like Bots that just go to town on you
you know and make you know give you
death threats Etc I know how it goes and
can I ask you something um yeah
a lot of people I saw online saying this
and I can't lie I this was my first
reaction although I've totally come
around that's not how I feel now okay
but reading the text message a lot of
people saw that and said
yes he's a douche
but he's setting his
boundaries and expectations very clear
and so if she can't reach so how how is
it abused if she if he's saying these
are my expectations and if you can't
reach that then
well let's just break up
because it's very manipulative because
you don't know what all the experiences
that have led up to now this list of
boundaries most likely he's been doing
other tactics that have messed with her
sanity to be quite honest with you from
what I read they were also going to
couples therapy there was already this
going on actually one other thing I read
that really yeah made me turn on him
their therapist was his like best friend
that he was like doing a project with I
think he was work he was working with a
therapist who was like his best body it
was like so [__] up in that sense can
you fact check that somebody I know I
read something about that yeah we'll see
there's also that's my abuser did to me
too and it ended up backfiring on him
actually he tried to get me into therapy
every time I tried to leave him I was
crazy crazy and I I was my self-worth
was very low I didn't want real love and
so he put me in therapy and the
therapist ended up being like you gotta
leave oh for real yeah that's how I got
out of there good for that that's how I
escaped so it worked out but anyways if
it's not that you know like the
mediation experience so that I happened
in my happened to my divorce was the
opposite of that it was basically like a
Sarah Brady situation where it wasn't
neutral you know and a lot of bad things
ended up happening to me in that
mediation because no one was looking out
for my best interest
um so I believe that like that's that's
pretty scary but the thing is like you
don't know what was happening around
that conversation and what led up to
that list of boundaries to me when I
read that I didn't really see um man
saying he's crazy or taking any type of
accountability I saw him kind of putting
her down and putting him up like this is
what I want to know this is the kind of
woman I need and what I want and you
just don't measure up so if you're not
gonna measure up then you better you
can't have me that's like how I felt it
and I felt that before by abusive men is
that they use these
very you almost don't even catch it like
it's so smooth almost but if you re-read
it a few times you'll be like oh he's
putting her down
he's putting her down and he's putting
him up like I don't I don't really like
a woman who like surfs with men
and like I'm I'm pretty chill like I
have my [__] together so and you're just
like Ugh okay so I mean yeah the text is
is just the tip of the iceberg in terms
everything else that's going on
correct I just think that was a symptom
that was just part of many other things
that were obviously going on behind
closed doors with them you know or in
conversations and I mean she obviously
felt very charged
to you know release those messages and
so most of the time when that happens
like that person's really asking for the
world to validate that you know they're
not
crazy because that's what abusers really
make you feel like I mean it took me a
lot many many
I had to process my abuse during my
first pregnancy and it was really rough
you know like you just even there's some
days I sometimes wake up is that how it
you know you're it's so [__] honestly
like it takes a lot of willpower to
really get yourself out of the
manipulation that's very subtle and
slowly happens over a period of time
well I'm seeing here that Jonah Hill
made a documentary with his therapist
about some like specific type of therapy
they developed which sounds like super
pseudosciency like lame [__] and I think
that it was the same therapist they were
doing uh
uh couples counseling with but I don't
know if it was yeah I don't know if it
was so don't quote me on that also
allegedly I don't know nothing I'm a
goldfish
I'm gonna start saying I'm a goldfish I
don't know anything
I think a woman can by the way well I
think it might play well with the judge
do you think women can get away with the
Goldfish thing I don't know so I want to
um I guess
let's see Brady's text also mentions
separate couples therapist so it was
different when according to the time
okay it was a different one okay okay
so I'm sure it was recommended though by
this guy although his therapist is like
his best homie who's probably just
validating all of his psychotic
Tendencies yeah
so I wanted to ask you about
one other person that you had mentioned
on social media recently Seth macfarland
a Family Guy Fame
yeah
I'm I'm not red I I'm like
can't do it now okay fair enough
um
but I meant what I said
you know
um
I definitely meant what I said and I
said things earlier too that nobody
really listened to like I don't know
November of last year are you
comfortable repeating what you already
said or I mean you don't I'm not going
to pressure you at all we can move right
past it yeah no it's already on it's on
Twitter I don't even know if I deleted
all of them per se but I was like pretty
triggered
um and you know all I gotta say is like
just just know or look into you know how
many rape jokes that guy wrote
um over there as well like if you think
punked makes those guys you know look
like whatever like definitely check out
family guys
um
rape jokes wow
um they're
there's a lot of there there are a lot
of them and he plays the voice of one of
them of what you know Quagmire
and right yes they're a super funny
actual just like straight up like racist
sexual uh or not racist I mean rapist
sexual a predator yeah Predator it is I
always thought it was odd how they
portray Quagmire it's like
this dude is like
a rapist yeah yeah he even admits at one
point I'm pretty positive there's an
episode where he's like I'm a rapist to
um Peter or whatever
um so uh I don't so the Zoe 101 reunion
is happening tomorrow and as I
understand you weren't invited to that
no did you find that damn though no
neither was Dan though well that makes
more sense to me that they can't find
him they couldn't even find him to get
you know what I mean
no no he's in he's in Thailand he's in
Thailand um no I wasn't invited actually
I'm airing my my e predators
Daily Show tomorrow talking a little bit
um about it all like that's a good day
to air this while I'm about to give
birth I'll just like do it on the same
day
um the same day that I was once again
Uninvited but it was it's okay did it
surprise you that you weren't invited
it more surprised me when they got had a
reunion like I thought maybe when we
were getting close to 30 that we've like
moved past some of this
right and that was more shocking to me
like the reboot whatever
um but this is I don't know if I
mentioned this part but was what was
really messed up was
I came forward once again about them
basically bullying me
um throughout the entire show and right
after they did the whole reunion thing
Jamie ends up reaching out to me with
this fake apology and I was like I think
I was seven months pregnant around that
time with Nova and she sends me this
long thing and then at the end of it she
wants something from me of course so it
was like this apology like oh look
bygones be bygones and then at the end
it said will you be in my music video
that's that's crazy
it was very weird and I obviously was
like no I said it nicely though I was
like thank you so much for inviting me
but no like I'm going into like birth
soon I'm going on my baby moon or
whatever and I just made up a bunch of
like real excuses but also excuses to
not be a part of that and fast forward I
thought everything was chill to be
honest with you I just thought okay
Jamie finally so at least she did
Apologize even if it wasn't totally
genuine
um at least I got a text message from
her and I'll take it and then a few
months later she messages me and this is
right around the time Britney came
forward her testimony about what she
went through and I remember being like
Oh my God Jamie Lynn Spears is
you know I just whatever I was like oh
my God she's still like this and I was
trying to process it and then she texted
me and said can I send you something
and I was like uh I don't want you to
know where I live
like a little bit I was like I don't
want to give you my address
um and I don't know what you're sending
me this why don't you tell me what
you're sending me and then the next day
I find out the Jamie's book
is about to get released and I'm like
was she trying to send me her freaking
book and I was like wait what the hell
and then I get all these messages the
book leaked and she just told mad lies
about me in the book yeah
was it like defamatory [__] what did she
say about you
did the whole darvo effect thing where
she like just turned everything as if it
was me bullying her
onset and it's like what are you talking
about you ever consider taking action or
something
no I'm so exhausted with these people
there's only so much action I could do
even right now I'm doing action and nine
months pregnant and like maybe some
doctors wouldn't recommend it well the
good news is I don't think anybody read
that book
no I don't think so and the ones that
did they it was Elite yeah nobody nobody
wanted it nobody read it no but I did
get told so that's I came that's when I
came forward about even more so I was
like Jamie what the hell is this like
were you trying to send me a and I would
I would have appreciated if she just
told me also like hey
I wrote this book and this is how I feel
like can we hash some things out like
this is my memory can we talk about your
I would have loved an actual
conversation like what normal people do
you know but instead it was her just
sending me allegedly hypothetically
maybe this book that had all these lies
about me in it that is so sad very
it was so so she's a nobody now I'm
pretty sure right she's just the girl
that tried to steal her sister's money
isn't that right right and she has her
Paramount Plus show that she does
there's only one two three one of the
new one yeah why
because the world has no new ideas
nobody asked for his results by the way
I I looked up how many seasons of Zoe
want to wonder what there's only four
seasons so you were like a main star for
two of those Four Seasons yeah so
apparently it wasn't enough excluding
you from the reunion seems pretty
intentional
definitely it's okay though it's okay
because you know honestly I've learned
like I don't really want to be near you
know if you're not going to Value me as
a person like I don't need to be you
know hanging it's okay like I actually
I've gotten to the point where I'm like
I don't want to hang out with you you
know so it's fair now we both don't want
to hang out with each other at least
wait the show there was only four
seasons because Jamie got pregnant when
she was 16. yeah oh you didn't know that
I don't I
allegedly Jamie denies that and who's
the father Dan schnut no I'm just
kidding sorry there's that hole the
first her first born
but there's a lot of rumors there's like
fake conspiracy theories all about that
of course that's pretty young holy
smokes yeah it was pretty that's a big
experience for a 16 year old I mean for
me even at 27 it was a big experience
yeah like I can't imagine doing that at
16. like that's just
so
there's something else what was the
other thing
so Zoe 102 that's [__] weird oh yeah
here's something I wanted to ask you
about yeah you were in tiptoes you were
in the movie tiptoes you [__] know
tiptoes dude dude that movie is
legendary
and the role of a lifetime Gary Oldman
they thought he was going to win an
Academy Award for that yo Gary Oldman
literally walked on his knees I know I
could tell for watching it that he was
just on his knees with like a shoe glue
to him and they said it was a role of a
lifetime
in the trailer and in the role of a
lifetime Gary older stop yeah stop
yes that's from there that's from the
trailer they're they're Oscar baiting
wait what was your role in tiptoes
It's amazing And in the role of a
lifetime Gary Oldman
did the trailer get um claimed I don't
remember I think it may I think it did I
could test it can you believe they're
still [__] claiming the tiptoes
trailer of all goddamn things wait
they're not claiming it are they I'll
you go go and after we're done I'll send
uh one of us will send you the link the
trailer is Legendary Legendary okay you
have to send that to me because honestly
that was one of the most wild sets I've
ever worked on also what happened to
Matthew McConaughey have you seen him
lately
what he got real skinny what no dude
he's like started a cult oh yeah the
money he's dude like a get Rick get rich
quick thing with uh with uh what's his
name mom Robbins yeah Tony Robbins who's
another scumbag yeah what the hell it
was it's Art of Living dude I saw it
actually they posted a live stream on
YouTube that I was and then they removed
it and I was really disappointed because
it was gold but uh yeah why did they
remove it
sucks I don't think he was he was
actually nice he was nice on tattoos
he was you know who wasn't really that
nice though oh
Gary Oldman wasn't that nice Gary Allman
well it was a role of a lifetime he was
uh he was focusing hard he was in
character you know he was method yeah he
went home at night he walked around on
his knees
it's absolutely I can't believe that
movie ever got made I mean it was shot
shocking Matthew right yeah right for
anyone who doesn't know Matthew
McConaughey
has a dark secret that he hasn't told
his girlfriend his new girlfriend what
is the dark secret that his whole family
is Little People oh they say in the
movie they call them midgets which I
know I'm not supposed to say but like in
the I I feel like you guys need to know
that
it's so ridiculous film it makes no
sense here's Gary Oldman on his knees
pretending to be a little person
and so and then here's the best part his
girlfriend she gets pissed
that his whole family is little people
and she didn't tell him and then he's
got to go meet his crazy family they're
all little people and it's just so wacky
this is the craziest premise for a movie
of all time and you were there you were
there I was there I was I was there
I did it
so I actually well what was your role
what was your role were you what
character were you I I don't know man
what I was
um no I remember I do remember I was
Matthew McConaughey's cousin did were
you one of the little people
they never confirmed nor denied that you
were a little person at tiptons
you are one of the little people I was
pretty little wait how old were you at
the time
I think I was like six or okay you were
six and a little so you were a little
person technically I was I was
technically a little person I was I was
really legit a little person oh my God
yeah no I I can't believe you know
tiptoes I do I know all about tips it's
an incredible yeah because you because
he's tiptoeing around the The Dark
Secret that his family's little people
and also they tiptoe because they're
little and they want to appear bigger
taller it's a double meaning Gary
oldman's knees were tiptoeing dude he's
awesome uh here by the way since you
since you mentioned uh dear Matthew
McConaughey I'm gonna pull this up so
yes my son was he was headed off to camp
and before we went he shared a really
cool thing with me I said hey what are
you hoping to get from this
he said
bye-bye I just wanna bye-bye he didn't
say that buddy bye-bye
he didn't say it like that did he when
you get from this
he said
bye-bye I just want to meet new people
and do cool maybe he did I don't know
his wife is I think
Hispanic listen howdy stuff maybe maybe
he did say it like that thanks I just
want to meet people and do cool stuff
and that is about them and I was like
wow you are the most privileged
piece of [__] I've ever known
oh exactly
best reason to go and do something there
is in life isn't it
so I got an idea
oh no we got together we can meet new
people and do stop and also you pay me
yes I'm gonna do my first ever virtual
live event and it's called The Art of
Living and I'd like to invite you to
join me we're going to work on getting
in tune all right finding our frequency
not someone else's by learning how to
catch and create more green lights this
man won an Academy Award I'm pretty sure
this is the A-list actor doing some
straight D list yeah what are you
driving I don't know in our life I don't
get it I don't get it I don't understand
why it's like it's like why I don't know
because he's obviously wealthy enough uh
I don't know doesn't do it his wife is
Brazilian by the way so maybe his his
son is uh does say papa
I don't want to offend anybody here is
by the way the way he says it is just
unreal
here's the dink Dinklage was also in uh
tiptoes I think he was the only
um
little person potentially on set
well that's right I remember oh I
remember that scene he was a badass
he is a badass honestly yeah
he really that's what's her name is it
Patricia Arquette I think so
unbelievable yo during the trailer they
go starring all these people's
star-studded stunning in the role of a
lifetime and in the role of a lifetime
Gary Oldman I swear to God from the
trailer so not PC in any type of way
that movie would have been I would have
been probably protesting oh yeah no that
dude those people want nobody in that
movie wants anybody to remember
know that that movie exists yeah the
trailer why are they claiming the
trailer that's so obscene
all right so um I don't know Alexa is
there anything else you want to add I
mean oh yeah I wanted to ask you about
your eat Predators organization that
you've
uh put together I guess where what is
that
um yeah what is that you know
e-predators basically started out of
just kind of uh hopelessness
just straight up hopelessness and not
knowing what to do
um it was also kind of around the time
of the Johnny Depp like Amber Heard
um Fiasco and it was some dark times I
was like what do I do to actually feel
empowered as a Survivor and you know I
just randomly saw that Diplo I don't
know if anyone knows who Diplo is yeah
we know or I know okay all right so
Diplo is like best friends with my
abuser and he obviously also is an
alleged uh abuser and I saw that he was
having an all ages show in the middle of
the street out of a [__] ice cream
truck out of all things
um oh stop I can't even see his image
okay I just so the people know that's
that's Diplo I mean he's one of the
famous uh
EDM is it EDM I don't know yeah it's EDM
it's whatever he wants it to be honestly
he he yeah so I'm not like a fan
necessarily of the guy he doesn't have
really good accusations he was under a
criminal investigation
um he preys on young black girls
allegedly and um so yeah I saw that he
was playing out of an ice cream truck on
Melrose Avenue and I just felt the need
to tell the kids possibly that we're
watching the show that he was in the
middle of a criminal investigation like
just in case I don't know like they
should know and that's the thing with
the music industry is like these guys
will straight up be in the middle of
criminal investigations and they'll just
put them around potential victims you
know so I went with a couple of my
Survivor friends and we just went to
across the street at first to protest
the truck and it was ironically called
Eat the Rich
popsicles and it was like a whole art
whatever Diplo yeah he's a rich man it's
like so we're eating him I'm confused so
anyways I came up with the idea to have
my protest sign be eat predators and I
never thought it was going to end up
becoming what ended up becoming I
thought it was just going to be one
night protest sign but we and my husband
ended up dragging me into the middle of
the crowd
um of the people that were listening to
Diplo play and that night I really got
to see how people treated survivors I
got knocked around some girl took my
phone from me a guy shredded my protest
sign and that's when I realized while
survivors are are not safe you know I
wasn't doing anything in that crowd I
was just holding the sign
um and violence Came Upon me basically
and my husband you were just holding a
sign that said eat Predators yeah and
people why were they attacking you
because they were defending Diplo they
knew that you were accusing him of yeah
allegedly correct hypothetically you are
allegedly accusing him of allegedly
being hypothetically a predator in my
opinion in Minecraft
yes there we go
that's perfect we're we're cleared we're
totally cleared here yeah that's what
was happening and I was like wow so my
no one like if you know for example if
anyone else was protesting something
like why would you ever go violent
against someone protesting against a
predator like you know like if you I saw
e Predators I just be like okay whatever
even if I wanted to listen to the music
I would just keep listening to the music
not Shred the person's sign and grab the
phone like it felt it was a wake-up call
for me personally and so that's what led
me to digging more into enablers like
how do these alleged Predators survive
in these industries how do they Thrive
how do they get more access to more
victims and that's when I started to
realize I wanted to look more into the
enablers not just the alleged predators
and so I started doing the digging and
let's just say it was like the Catholic
Church on steroids the entertainment
industry it really it really really
honestly is and they been covering up
and moving these alleged Predators
around and not doing anything about it
and a lot of victims could have been
spared their abuse if this industry
actually did something about the
allegations when they first heard about
them so I started to eat Predators I
started going to these institutions like
going to these record labels
one of them being a lawyer
um who was the lawyer of my abuser and
the lawyer of Kevin Spacey and The Lure
of Diplo allegedly when he was at
Berkeley he um I can't say this he he
like you should look it up on Business
Insider what he allegedly did in
Minecraft
in Minecraft and now he's a lawyer who
represents alleged abusers and Bullies
survivors like me out of our road to
Justice and so I stood up to him and his
law firm with a couple of survivors and
eventually got those court documents to
be told to the world because survivors
deserve to know you know if their lawyer
is an alleged predator
you know himself right and I felt that
you know we deserve full disclosure so
that's kind of how I started and it's
from my own personal experience in the
industry and now that I'm a pregnant mom
I was like okay I can't be on the
streets that often so I took it to the
screens and now I'm making a show
basically about it called e-pretters
daily where I basically just protest via
talking about all these different
individuals is that a YouTube thing yeah
it comes out tomorrow oh
let me see do you have a what's the
channel how do people watch it it
predators and it should say Alexa
Nicholas okay so we'll put a link in the
description for that so you're putting
out your first episode tomorrow what
kind of show uh can people expect it's
gonna be kind of like the onion but the
Predators
um it's like
pretty much like a lot of satire going
through predatory behavior in the
industry and it's you know my personal
experience through it and also my
commentary
um on these headlines that sounds
interesting I think a lot of people will
be interested in that
thank you a lot of and where can people
go uh support you follow you I know
there's a lot of people here who are
your admirers now if they weren't before
and they would like to go uh support you
so that's so sweet on Instagram I match
the source and on Tick Tock I'm Alexa H
Nicholas and then on YouTube
I'm you Predators so Annie Predators on
Instagram as well so we'll put all the
the links in the description guys so you
don't have to worry it'll all be there
just go to
the description
um I actually if I had a couple more
questions it just came to my mind if
you're okay because you had oh sorry
what I said let's do it okay cool you
had mentioned that the Amber Heard case
had put you in a bad place and I'm
curious what about that put you in a bad
place
um how I saw people
making fun
of
her
um even if like people didn't believe
her it the way that I saw the worlds
dehumanizing her
um it made it just triggered me into
that's how survivors feel all the time
anyways like there's very little support
most the time when you're coming
especially when you're going up against
someone who's extremely powerful
um and more powerful than you
technically
it's it's dehumanizing it's humiliating
most people don't like you for doing
that you lose your job you get canceled
you know and so when I saw this like
huge actress like Amber Heard just
getting totally dragged through God like
just a viral hell
um and having doesn't matter if you
believe her or you don't believe her
that's not really what I was triggered
by it was just by how we were making
jokes out of rape
um and how we like like Family Guy how
we were like making jokes you know about
possibly someone's real life trauma and
you know I was in the middle of a
lawsuit against my abuser at the time
and it almost I mean it almost you can
see how that could silence
so many survivors I was pretty surprised
by
it seemed like even a lot of people who
are generally would be like supportive
of of victims like there was
yeah I'm
it was like just an incredible wave of
just absolute hate for her specifically
and and I was surprised by it I mean
like you said even if even if she's not
in the right
it's still pretty stunning how cruel
people were being towards her I I
thought I agree I I was just blown I was
blown away and then you would just see
all these videos of that guy you know
drawing banging things around and like
there was so much love and respect for
him and the woman it just it felt it was
very triggering and also I just think
maybe it was also like genetic I mean
like you know ancestral trauma of just
being like whoa all of the love and
supports going towards the guy you know
and the woman is just getting eaten
alive like it was like watching someone
get eaten alive you know what I think it
was there's a lot of people who are like
women have gone too far feminism has
gone too far yeah so they saw this
they're like here's here it is the
undeniable opportunity where she lied
about all this [__] and he is totally
innocent and so we're gonna make the
ultimate example of her although I have
to say I've been reading more and more
stuff and I feel like there is a public
perception now that is somewhat shifting
uh more in support of her I do think so
I've read a lot of stuff and I mean some
of the text messages I read from Johnny
Depp's were just
[__] vile like vile the [__] he was
saying about her was just so vile man it
was really bad he literally talked about
like wanting to rape a dead body
that one that's fine of her the corpse
of her okay that's that's interesting
and yeah making sure she's dead you know
um and you know you read that and I did
stand up for Amber Heard you know and I
got eaten alive for that and so that was
also like another like triggering thing
because I felt like I wasn't safe as a
Survivor once again to like have my own
opinion about something and then survive
I saw survive what I really saw honestly
was survivors attacking other survivors
and that's why I ended up coming up with
like survivors United at first now it's
changed more to power to survivors
because it's kind of hard to unite
everybody most the time it's kind of an
idealistic approach but at the time I
just saw survivors fighting with
survivors and trying to show like what
trauma was more important than this
trauma and like it just felt like a very
dark time and and when I was witnessing
that it was just so sad because we just
came out of this Progressive Movement
where survivors felt support to come
forward and then this happened and it
was survivors going up against one
another which you know it's a conquer
divide this yeah this was the big rubber
band I think because why it was so
outsized the hate for her there's
apparently a new Netflix documentary
come out called Depp versus her do we
have any do we know what's the angle
what's that gonna be
I'm interested in that it's going to be
August 16th on Netflix I'm reading
that's very interesting I hope it's not
like I have a feeling if it was just
like all Johnny Depp propaganda it
wouldn't be that interesting of a
documentary would it true because we've
all heard it a thousand times that side
huh
I'm curious I'm curious to see it just I
mean there were so many girls that were
silenced from that it seemed to me and
I'm not super familiar with all the
facts so I'm probably speaking at a turn
here but you're a goldfish I'm a
goldfish at the end of the day but it
seemed to me that they were both pretty
abusive to each other and the support he
got was outsized and the hate she got
was outsized it seemed like they had
both done pretty [__] up things to
each other
yeah I mean the thing is is that when
you know when I look back at myself in
my abusive fraudulent relationship
um there are times that I wasn't I'm not
proud of necessarily who I was
in that during that time but that was
because that person had a lot to do with
bringing that out in me you know like
that survival move that aggressive I
look back now and I'm like well I'm not
like that at all with my husband you
know what I mean like I look at things
that I said then and then I see who I am
in a safe environment that's not abusive
and very loving
um and you're like wow that's a huge
difference so at the same time like yeah
I don't think anyone's perfect at all
but at the same time knowing my own
personal experience I'm always a little
suspicious with that because sometimes
these abusers really bring out the worst
in you you know what I mean and they're
triggering you constantly or just not
yourself you're really not yourself and
so who knows what that you know I I
would none of us were actually obviously
in the room there but what I've read
from the London trial was enough for me
to go she was abused you know
for in my opinion like well there was
enough I think I think it's possible and
again I might be speaking and it turned
that I think he may have also been on
the receiving end of abuse from her
who knows but really what it felt like
was she was a lot younger than him there
was a little bit of a power Dynamic
there maybe she wasn't a person that all
of us would chill with maybe she's not
your BFF but there was abuse happening
there and I think people got so way more
caught up in it being a sport and
picking a team then like respecting
trauma you know what I mean you know
what I mean like it was about serious
things and people were making a
spectacle of it for sure it was scary
well it was like gangbusters man I don't
know if you noticed like there were so
many YouTube channels and twitch
streamers who like were they were like
it's Johnny Depp Amber Heard all day
every day they had like 90 clips of it
yes and it was it was in Circus kind of
I got death threats like I've never gone
death threats and actually the ver the
second time I got death threats was when
I came forward about Jonah Hill but the
first time I got death threats like a
crazy amount was just for posting
something about Amber Heard once and
when I saw that I was like this is
this is wild why so much hatred like
what the hell is going it was very weird
yeah and I noticed that too his um
his supporters were so freaking
they were just so determined man but I
do think people who who are listening
who are hardcore Johnny deppers who
think like Amber heard's a liar and
deserves everything I would tell you
guys just to
read some more stuff coming up because
I've personally been influenced by some
of the the new stuff people are saying
about it because it you know when the
dust settles and you can look at things
retrospectively uh I think that that
it's there's some new Revelations and
New Perspectives on it that are really
interesting
yes and I honestly would like to add
that you know abusers do tend to make
things look really messy and complicated
on purpose to drown out most of the time
the victim's story
um or the truth of something that's
happening like the Messier it gets I'm
always very suspicious because that's
what my abuser would tend to do was deny
deny deny things and then also kind of
stir the pot to make it very complicated
when actually when I would go to therapy
it was very simple
um and I was like whoa it is very simple
like why am I making this so complicated
I realized it was his influence
um and him creating so much complexity
actually create a lot of complicity
um for all of those around me not even
realizing that they were you know being
complicit in in the abuse that he was uh
committing so I want to ask you one more
question yeah
if you go back to like where this all
began I mean you were in a really sweet
spot you were on a huge show you were
the co-star and it seemed like you you
had like a really
potentially
wonderful path ahead of you of success
and wealth and uh and uh acting and like
a lot of people dream of this having
these opportunities is there any time
when you go back and think like that
they these people these these men they
stole this other
you who could have been out there doing
that
yes yeah
um many many nights
um I have cried over what men have done
to me and my career like if you look I
got married to a my groomer and my
abuser in 2012 and that was the last
year I worked
so he took like everything from me and
that's why I'm so passionate about what
I do because I didn't really start
processing it until I found out I was
giving birth to a girl
and it brought me to tears because I
realized how am I going to explain to
her
um if she does end up identifying as a
woman what that was like for me
identifying as a woman how would I share
my inner world with my child and I was
very confused I don't I didn't know how
to and I had to do like a lot
of internal work to kind of figure out
what had happened to me what I feel
about it and what I want to do about it
now and what I decided was and I want to
make sure this never happens to my
daughter
um ever I don't want her to ever go into
any work environment for example and
feel that if she stands up for the right
thing she's going to lose her job
um and that's what happened to me and
that's what happened to countless people
mostly people that aren't white males
um that's what happens when you stand up
against these individuals we're the ones
who get canceled you know and it wasn't
cancel culture
um for thousands of years when it was
happening to us but now that white men
have little breaks in their careers
because they did something it's
something called cancel culture which is
a real bummer because really if you look
at history there are so many individuals
that have lost their art their careers
their voices
um
for coming forward or standing up
against Power and that's
where I'm at now where I can't sit in
the gutter of what has happened to me I
chose to help others hopefully
um by sharing my stories and also
getting active in whatever way possible
so I can make Nova proud I hope that's
I hope that's what I end up doing
I'm sure you will yeah thank you I I
there's one more thing oh it keeps
coming a moment one more thing I want to
ask you if you have time I look back at
those sets
and yeah these these situations with
kids they're like they're regulated by
by the state I think or by the federal
government but there are regulations
about how kids need to be treated on set
but then when you go to and and see what
even happened to you even despite all
the regulations so if you go like to
what's happening on YouTube with like
family vlogging channels there's no
regulations there's no protection for
the kids
this I've always thought was a big
problem and there's no oversight there's
nobody there to advocate for the kids
even if it's their parents you know what
I mean who's doing it because they're
the parents self-interest is all mixed
up with their kids self-interest this
seems to me like a huge problem is this
something you've thought about
absolutely I mean I get asked a lot of
times for media Outlets if I feel that
there should be a such thing as child
stars at all like should children be and
I don't I honestly do not believe do you
think I you think children should not be
allowed to act no because I don't think
it's consensual if they can't consent to
like the Army and they can't consent to
you know you know sex with a funking
adult for example like I don't really
know if
a child can consent to selling
themselves in a type of way also what I
don't like about it is what I wish why I
also personally wish that I wasn't a
child star is kids should enjoy
exploring their creativity without
capitalism tainting it you know like I
never got that I never got to just like
explore all the different creative sides
of me because it was all about the the
financial app like the financial aspect
always was a part of it and it kind of
Tainted my relationship with creativity
for a while I always felt I had to there
was had to be a financial exchange with
creation and it really messed with my
head and when I see kids for example
that aren't in Industries like that they
get to explore their creativity in a
very healthy way without capitalism
trying to gain something you know from
them there seems to be no question about
it I mean child actors on whole seem to
have a pretty bad outcome it seems like
I mean that's that's easily recognizable
when you look at it I'm surprised I
survived you know there's days where you
know I look around and some of my
friends do not
and it's sad you know I'm I'm so I told
my therapist I'm like did I really
survive like I feel like I'm gonna wake
up one day and I'm gonna be way more on
the floor than I am you know and it it
puts a toll on you so I just don't feel
like kids should
feel that they can consent to something
so
with an institution behind it that can
not only exploit them
um but also pressure them into doing
things that they don't necessarily want
to do because I just realized after a
while like I I realized do I want to be
an actress like you don't even know what
you want to be at five years old you
know you might change your mind
um but what happens when you put all
your eggs in one basket for example it's
very hard to
get out of that so that's why it's
important that kids don't feel stuck in
something early on just through their
parents which is literally what these
family Vlogs are it's like you're at
home your home is your work and your
bosses are your parents it's scary that
yeah see that freaks
that freaks me out I honestly I I don't
support that whatsoever it's just too
much it's like and also do you need the
kids like I don't know I even feel kind
of uncomfortable when I do like you know
when I had Nova
all these different companies wanted to
like give things for me to promote
and you know I would like there would be
a diaper and I would have Nova already
in my Instagram stories you know and I
would tag the thing and it was still
very hard for me I was like oh it would
trigger me a little bit like am I
exploiting my child you know like you
think that because of your own personal
experience I was like no obviously I'm
not doing that but there is this fine
line where we all have to be very much
aware in the virtual realm of how we are
uh incorporating our children into our
virtual lives I think having awareness
around is not going to be a bad thing
like just being a little bit aware of
that fact
um it doesn't mean you have to be
perfect I don't think any of us are
going to be perfect Millennial parents
like what do you want you know like
there's so much but being aware of it I
think and having the conversations
around it is not going to hurt anybody I
think that is important okay Alexa
Nicholas what a joy what a pleasure this
conversation went way longer than I
thought it would because it was just so
it was just so fascinating endlessly
fascinating endlessly interesting and
insightful and I really appreciate you
calling in and sharing all that with us
thank you so much thank you for having
me and listening to me of course and
everyone who wants to check out more of
her again all the links are in the
description and her new show is coming
out uh tomorrow on YouTube so check it
out in a role of a lifetime Alexa
Nicholas
who's uh uh of from tiptoe Fame
thank you that's what I want to be known
for anyways thank you so much all right
have a great evening thank you again
thank you so much have a good one bye
everyone
thank you bye
the role of a lifetime and in the role
of a lifetime dude the tiptoe connection
that is crazy it was everything to me
she saw Gary Oldman creeping around on
his knees
she was there
that's awesome that's like being like
witnessing Pearl Harbor or 911 yeah
where were you at
she was there
um wow
that was way longer than I thought it
would be we did like a full interview
with her that was like over two hours
[__] yeah
we're at three hours right now
what do you guys think about all that
I was fascinated the whole time yeah
she's been through
so much her book would be so long
does she not have a book she should if
she doesn't she should 100 percent
the thing that is really good
is I feel like there would be a lot of
skepticism and doubt about everything
she says but like when Britney came out
and co-signed everything that I feel
like is so powerful for her
yeah
um and a really just a great thing that
happened uh Sam and Cat actually is this
is what I remember
thank you Cam no this is from Reddit
actually that was from Reddit thank you
I used to watch this show thank you guys
yes with the feet at the bottom you
shame on you
she's so cool I loved her and Zoe 101. I
never even goddamn heard of that show oh
my God one of my I mean now I take it
out of the the list obviously so you're
a lot younger so I think I was way way
too old for that but when I was a kid
when I didn't understand that was one of
the faves
dude Dan Schneider what a sick [__] that
dude is
you know I was thinking I was sort of
talking to Ahmad Avery on the side maybe
a Content cop on here I mean actual
Court as well but he needs real core
yeah but it's crazy how much stuff
people don't know about and that Ariana
video was insane yeah that was rough
yeah yeah yeah yeah he needs the
judicial system
we gotta go find him in Thailand
he's for sure somewhere in Southeast
Asia has to be
yeah Nickelodeon paid him seven million
dollars to break his contract and [__]
off because there was a bunch of like
you know how you know how far seven
million goes in Thailand oh yeah
okay the Seth macfarland stuff is pretty
explosive I know she doesn't want to go
there so I didn't want him probe too I
don't want to probe at all
but uh and then the Jonah Hill thing
Jason schlong
I you know what I like about her she's
not afraid to say name names it's
awesome like and I get that people don't
want to do that right because who the
[__] wants
all that smoke well I thought it was
awesome when you asked her like have you
been contacted legally and she's like no
because I tell the truth and people know
that it's the truth and they don't want
it to be looked into that's that's the
ticket right because if somebody sues
her for defamation it opens their all
their skeletons exactly it opens up all
the deaf depositions it opens at all to
Discovery to investigation so someone
like Seth macfarland be like hey she
defamed me then it's like okay well
let's see I had now can investigate
every facet of your life right
but I was scared for you know because I
I want to make sure she wasn't going to
come on here and get in trouble I
assumed somebody had already come at her
legally but
that's surprising nobody has
badass
but I was but yeah she names names I
think that that's really Brave and
incredible you don't see a lot of people
that do that
you know
I mean she's like yeah this dude Jason
schlong's roommate was like statutory
raping my friend and here's his name and
face yep I was like yo
we're speaking the fact she said that's
what that's that's good today I only
want to talk about the facts that's
right that's so me right now
uh I saw a lot of people getting
triggered over the um
Johnny Depp stuff as I knew it would you
see how
grumpy
I knew people aren't ready to move on
from that yet
but I I look forward to more stuff about
that coming out I really do I really do
I think that over time we're gonna learn
that Johnny Depp was not this
innocent victim that's just I don't
that's my feeling that's some stuff that
I've read
Justin schlong not Jason schlong
but I understand uh
if you loved What's Eating Gilbert Grape
or whatever it's uh Pirates it's all
Captain Jack it's all Captain Jack
Stands
definitely
she was not saying oh people were like
men can be abused she never said that
women can't be abusers oh she never said
that
obviously but I think overall that was
uh
that was great
yeah that's what I think I think they
were personally I think they were both
abusers that that's what I got they're
both
treated each other horrifically you know
what I mean
uh but uh it's not easy to talk about
people are still charged up about it
there it is
Alexa Nicholas everybody
fantastic
um
let me see I mean we we've been going
for a minute
it's already 4 30 [__]
I can talk about
actually I could talk about one more
thing the fantanos being sued by
Activision is pretty interesting
our boy melon fantano is being sued and
this is so interesting because it's
exactly what the [__] we're doing to
these scumbags these scum brands that
use my voice to sell their [__]
so here's what happened
fantano friend of the show
music critic everybody knows him
so
okay so they you he had this really
viral sound you guys probably remember
that's enough slices okay enough slices
there was like a video of someone
cutting the pizza
you know what I'm talking about
everybody knows that right that's enough
slices you could pull it maybe
so he had this viral
Sound by the way his had fifty thousand
mine has a hundred thousand I just don't
know if anybody wanted the numbers on
that
[Applause]
it is relevant
I think
and so he was hitting him up and being
like yo Activision one of the biggest
richest gaming companies in the world
why are you using oh here it is actually
this is perfect
save me a slice
that's good okay that's good yeah that's
all right that's good okay okay all
right okay all right okay that's good
that's good it's it's enough slices
I did not know that that was Anthony oh
you didn't no that's that's I don't have
that sound that's all Anthony wow
congratulations and so that's amazing
so I guess I don't have the one that
Activision used because they erased it
or do you have it
oh Dan is that Dan sitting at me or
somebody else it's Dan yeah initially it
was me but Dan's been in here the dance
yeah hi again hi girl hi Dan at home
sick girl
miss you girl did I ever say why he
wasn't here yeah he's sick I think he's
not here because he's jealous of me Dan
block me Dan
show me why are you showing a b
hi girl we love you girl get better Dan
do it better
Dan's at home doing this I guarantee it
yeah he did
so Anthony
they use the sound to promote a Crash
Bandicoot sneaker
super commercial use by a massive
business and he says them Yo y'all gotta
pay me
because you use that [__] in your in
your ad
and he's 100 right
okay
he said fantana allegedly claim that the
use of the audio created confusion
mistake or deception about his
involvement 100 you have
a right to your likeness okay giant
media companies don't get to use your
voice or your face or whatever it is to
sell their [__]
without
your permission that's not how it works
people just because it was on a tick
tock
okay
so here now scum scan uh scam division
scum division
now there's now they came back and and
uh they're not net they're not really
suing in but they came back
here let me read this the corporation
claimed that fantano demanded it
immediately paying substantial monetary
damage in the six figures ballpark
uh if they didn't pay up fantana said
his lawyers told Activision they'd
better be prepared to defend a lawsuit
fantano allegedly claimed that the use
of the audio created yeah so 100 agree
with fantano and this is really sneaky
what Activision's doing they're trying
to muddy the water to make fantano look
like he's greedy
and whatever they want to say oh he the
lawyer this is just lawyer [__] they
posture all the time you know what I
mean
you go to your lawyer I want ten
thousand dollars you're like okay cool
we asked them for 250 000.
that's how these this is how these
people think
you know
so um
they put out a press release I think
this Rolling Stones article trying to
look at this they try to make it sound
absurd Anthony fantanos courting
lawsuits over his Tick Tock pizza meme
okay [__] you guys
that's that is like a that's a really
shitty way how about this and how about
this headline Activision stole Anthony
fantano's voice to sell Crash Bandicoot
sneakers [__] you I don't think
anybody's gonna like that and why should
Anthony fantano uh
why should he let Activision how much of
those [__] worth you know what
I mean [__] them
y'all don't know how the law works all
of a sudden because tick tock's out
like I've had media people I've done
commercials like the media people are so
anal they sign a release if there's art
in the background you if you don't have
the artist's direct written consent you
have to remove it you can't wear shirts
with logos like they know how the law
works but all of a sudden Tick Tock
comes out and now Activision wants to be
able to use anyone's sound for any
purpose [__] that
you know what I mean hell no
fantano's threats laid out in a letter
issued Activision centered around right
of publicity exactly claims for false
endorsement
even though the audio clip has
activation argued is available for
public use on the app you morons there's
a big difference between people
using it for their personal
entertainment use and commercial use of
Activision using it to sell Crash
Bandicoot sneakers you fox
the audio in question has been used in
over 54 000 videos and again mine was a
hundred thousand and I don't know if
anyone's Counting
was anybody accounting
not looking for I can't find it
but fantano uh so let's see
check this out these scumbags
these scumbags got a statement from
Activision's lawyers look what they said
about him in an apparent effort to even
further profits from the slices video oh
greedy fantano with the slices video
Pantano has embarked on a scheme whereby
he selectively threatens to sue certain
users of the slices audio unless they
pay him extortionate amounts of money
for their alleged use [__] you the
lawsuit reads notwithstanding that
thousands of tick tock videos containing
the slice audio have been available and
ticked off for years no [__]
y'all really pretending like you don't
know the difference with commercial use
fantana suddenly decided that
Activision's video infringed his public
publicity rights and constituted a false
endorsement dumbasses
yeah suddenly exactly do does Jimmy does
Jimmy [__] what whoever
lip syncing to the sound is he endorsing
a product [__]
in response to the threats Corporation
claims they took offer to take down the
video and eventually did
but they were met with a aforementioned
ultimatum fantano claimed
that the use of audio clip yada yada
blah blah
the critics seemingly thought the threat
of Allah would get him paid but now he's
won being sued again this is moronic
it's misleading he's not being sued
they filed a
uh what's it called declared okay so
they file they're seeking a declaratory
judgment so they basically just went to
a judge and was like let's just resolve
this
they're not suing him [__] who wrote
this dude this is this this is as hacky
as the James Charles article I swear to
God man
this is basically just a paid promo from
Activision trying to
it's like why do they even care just pay
him a hundred thousand dollars [__]
but I'm just you know I mean
just let them just pay him off or you
don't have to pay him that much just pay
him off man you guys [__] up why you
gotta sue him over it or not he's not
being sued but why you guys be dicks
over it go to the media try to paint him
out like the back Activision's making
someone feel like the bad guy the most
predatory [__] [__] dicks in the
gaming industry Activision the kings of
microtransactions are accusing Anthony
fantana of being greedy
that's rich
Activision who literally ruined blizzard
and I'm trying to enjoy Diablo 4 but
it's [__] the game [__] sucks because
the Activision
y'all just buy [__] video game
companies and then ruin them
let me read the first paragraph here
imagine going through the entire process
of securing a law degree in hopes of
presenting clients in meaningful court
cases only to ultimately end up
defending them in a lawsuit surrendered
around the use of a 19 second Tick Tock
audio that's the reality for it for
that's the reality for attorneys
representing Anthony fantano the YouTube
music critic who has been named as a
defendant in a lawsuit from video game
developers Activision
publishing you are literally the dumbest
person alive
who wrote this
yeah I'm sure the law the law the
lawyers are like no this is below me
Activision stealing my clients audio for
commercial use is below me I did not go
to law school for this
I went to law school for something
better than this
uh so dismissive so pathetic how much
did you get paid by Activision did they
did they even pay you dollars or they
pay you in like uh
Activision bucks like what Beauty Box V
bucks
did they even pay you cash you sell out
you probably did it for V bucks loser
probably give you an exclusive amount
for one of their dog [__] games
iron ironically that might be worth a
lot of money yeah I was kind of raising
my eyes exclusive amount exclusive let's
talk let's go
um
they said and again the dick sucking of
Activision continues
in any event no reasonable consumer was
taken mistakenly believe that fantana
who admits that users had no idea the
slice's audio featured his voice I did
sponsored or endorsed Activision or it's
video merely because the slices audio
was included in that video it doesn't
matter it's his voice
you don't get to put anybody's voice on
an ad it's simple why are you guys
pretending to know that's not [__] up
to the contrary fantana's Odin mission
that the slices audio isn't is a
Tick-Tock meme holy undercuts any such
assertions I can't believe they actually
wrote this members of the public are no
more confused about fantana's
involvement with the video than they are
with any of the other thousands of tick
tock videos containing this is audio I
mean so obtuse how could you how could
you write this
why are they taking this fight up
so yeah I mean this is exactly what I'm
doing when I'm sending legal letters to
people who use my uh
use my sound the uh
uh I don't know whatever you know what I
mean they can't use my voice to sell
[__] it's that simple if you want to
sell [__] using my voice you need to
talk to me
and Anthony fantana is 100 right and I
do not like
they're like you know who's right this
billion dollar corporation who's trying
to steal this YouTuber's audio
it's a real uh David versus Goliath and
the big evil Anthony fantano
is bullying the small little helpless
Activision
[__] you
what is this division CEO Bobby kotec
knew for years about sexual misconduct
allegations as video game giant oh
brother don't even get me started Bobby
there's a lot of Jews from Bobby good
old Bobby
this dude doesn't even game he's the
[__] dumb as he ruined all my
favorite games dude Diablo 4 should have
been a great game yeah it sucks yeah for
no [__] reason
that's the game I'm playing bro like
he's the dude that Kicks Down the door
of the developers and goes we need this
game out next week the shareholders
demand it they're like it's not done we
need like another year put it out now
[__] you Bobby
get your money from somewhere else not
Anthony fantano
Go cover up some more sexual
uh misconduct allegations [__] there's
a lot of things on him allegedly
it's so confusing to me that they're
taking this fight up it's just so
bizarre
huh
well
that was it that was all I wanted to say
so Anthony if you are watching this
fantano we are united
I got your back brother
please stop bullying Activision Anthony
they're big they're big and they're so
defenseless little Activision I was
bullied
red hair
Dan shut up dude you're sick don't chat
don't even type in chat
Dan says it sucks Ethan has like 200
hours in D4 yeah and it should be a
better game It's upsetting because I put
a lot of time into it you should be a
good judge exactly it sucks or not yeah
come on though no it doesn't need to
have been playing with my friends for
plenty of hours they're just making it
worse by nerfing the game sucks the end
game sucks they could have put so much
more effort in
to building out a good end game that was
like engaging and long lasting and don't
even get me started I'm sick of this
game
that that the world they built this
whole open world it all looks the same
thing when you played the old Diablo
games you traveled to different biomes
new enemies new environments this game
doesn't have any of that [__] lazy
you know
ah
forget about it huh
whack division thank you blizzard Wolfie
okay this uh Lucas said Ethan personally
I don't find this girl's story
interesting but I love your content
anyways thanks didn't ask
why did you even type that like what
actually possessed you to share that
opinion
you need to leave
the league okay well that's about it
guys I had um
had a great time here a really fantastic
guest despite what uh
gotta find their name
despite what that one commenter said
Lucas
was it Lucas thank you yeah Lucas and
can you grab his Discord so I can ask
him for permission next time and when we
have a call in I want to go I want to go
over it with him okay to make sure it's
not boring for him
he doesn't pay five dollars to watch
right me talk to people
I'm kidding I love you guys
um
thank you guys for being here
tomorrow we'll be back leftovers is
finally coming back I know I know we've
been gone we've been sick Hassan's been
gone
but we're back tomorrow let's go
oh do we have super chess people
shouldn't read
um
Dan usually um
spearheads that movement I sent a couple
of shots let me just scroll up and get
them
what's that I sent a couple in Discord
oh you did here let me read it it's hard
for me to obviously to do the show and
read the super chats
uh are they pretty high up because I'm
scrolling up up a lot yeah I'm getting
them hold on
but yeah we'll be back tomorrow thank
you to our wonderful
members you guys
do so much to help support the show it's
very meaningful thank you guys and to
everybody else who watches as well thank
you so much my BF Kim is turning 31
tomorrow he would die happy if Ethan
wished him happy birthday from Sweden
31 [__] you
they're saying yeah uh I should make you
guys Swedish FICA I can do though happy
birthday to Kim
who can now die happy
but I hope you don't I hope you live a
long healthy life
without lupus or anything like that
um saskia says could I get a happy
birthday shout out from my boyfriend
Jake
happy birthday Jake
my son Isaac turns 11 tomorrow yo come
on
he's not a he doesn't watch this show
right
you're about to make me look like Jason
schlong serving up 11. you do have 11
why do you have 11 man I got it all man
so so go ahead do the whole thing
he's 11 I mean you're right you're right
yeah don't do it don't curse kid don't
don't let your 11 year old watch this
show it's not appropriate
all right for real though guys I gotta
go I gotta get the kiddos
uh thank you guys so much
lupus gang Mount the [__] up cheers my
dude
oh yeah it's Hassan's birthday yesterday
happy birthday to Hass and Abby
gossip Train Happy 25th birthday to my
bestie Kalyn
dogs are trade
you can play us out with that
he's here
I've been sharing my life online for
over 15 years I poured my heart out to
you and because of that I feel like I'm
talking to my friends but in the
beginning of my career I didn't really
understand that maybe there should be
some boundaries there there were times